ओके
सो अ वी आर लाइव नाउ आई
थिंक
चलिए ठीक है वी आर लाइव वी आर लाइव वी आर
लाइव वी आर लाइव यस लेट मी चेक
वंस एक बार मैं चेक कर लेता हूं अ जस्ट
वेट गाइ
जस्ट जस्ट
वेट
ओके यस तो एम ऑडिबल गाइस ऑडिबल एंड
विजिबल मेरी आवाज सही से जा रही है वीडियो
जा रही है आपको सही से प्लीज लेट मी
नो प्लीज कंफर्म कर दीजिए एक बार जल्दी
से यस सर
ओके
एकदम क्लियर है ठीक है ठीक है धन्यवाद
बहुत-बहुत धन्यवाद
आपका चलिए मैक्सिमम लोग आ चुके हैं यहां
पे क्या अच्छा ठीक है 25 लोग के आसपास आए
अभी फिलहाल चलो ठीक
है आने देते हैं कुछ लोग और ठीक है ओके तो
थोड़ा सा एक गैप हो गया बीच में आप लोगों
का 15 क्लास एंड 14 के बीच में आई होप कि
आपके लिए कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं हुआ होगा
राइट एंड ये एक अपॉर्चुनिटी की तरह आपने
ली होगी जो ये गैप हुई है इसको एज अ
अपॉर्चुनिटी आपने लिया होगा एंड आपको मजा
आया होगा ये जो गैप है उसमें रिवाइज करने
में एंड जिनका भी डे 15 तक नहीं हुआ था
कंप्लीट उसको कंप्लीट करने में राइट एम आई
राइट
गाइस बता दीजिए मुझे एक बार सभी लोग
प्लीज मैं देख रहा हूं
चैट आपको आपने इस गैप को जो तीन दिनों का
गैप था उसको अपॉर्चुनिटी की तरह लिया या
क्या कैसे लिया आप बताओ मुझे
आप
ओके एज अ अपॉर्चुनिटी लिया
ना बढ़िया बढ़िया
बढ़िया चलिए बहुत बढ़िया और आज की सेशन जो
है ना वह बहुत ही शानदार होने वाला है ठीक
है आज बहुत कुछ आप सीखने वाले हैं बहुत
कुछ जानने वाले हैं एक थोड़ा डिफरेंट अ
पर्सपेक्टिव देखने वाले हैं रिकॉन सेंस का
स्कैनिंग का हम समझने वाले हैं तो आज की
सेशन में प्लीज आप कंटिन्यू रहिएगा एंड तक
एंड आपको बहुत कुछ सीखने को बहुत कुछ
जानने को मिलेगा ठीक
है चलिए आज बहुत कम लोग हैं क्या बात
है फैला दो यार वीडियो के लिंक को शेयर कर
दो चारों तरफ फैला दो ताकि सभी लोग आ जाए
ठीक है बहुत कम लोग हैं फिर ऐसे कैसे काम
चलेगा और लाइक ठोक दो जो लोग भी अभी लाइक
नहीं ठोका सब लोग लाइक ठोक दो ठीक है ओके
चलिए एंड आप सबको मैं बताना चाहता
हूं आप सबको मैं यहां पर दिखा देना चाहता
हूं लेट मी शो यू वंस गाइस कि हमारा जो यह
बग बाउंट कोर्स है वोह कितना सक्सेसफुल हो
रहा है व आपको मैं अभी दिखाना चाहता हूं
लेट मी शो यू लेट मी शो एवरी बडी यह हमारा
डि फ्रक्स पेज है एंड यहां मैं आपको
एक्टिविटी पे लेके चलता हूं एंड आई वुड
लाइक टू
अ शो यू समथिंग कुछ बहुत लोग यहां पे टैग
करते हैं आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे जैसे एक
निखिल पटेल है इनको हॉल ऑफ फेम मिला हु है
हालांकि इनको रिवॉर्ड नहीं मिला ड्यू टू
p5 बट हॉल ऑफ फेम मिला एंड इन्होंने शेयर
किया था
दैट्ची तक पहुंच जाते हैं तो एक ग्रैजुअली
एक मतलब एक प्रोसेस है उस प्रोसेस के थ्रू
आप सबको जाना है ठीक है ओके यहां पे
मैं एक और दिखाना चाहता हूं यहां पे
मोहम्मद शाकल खान इनका भी एक आया था
इन्होंने एक पीवन रिपोर्ट किया था आई डोंट
नो द अपडेट अभी तक अपडेट इनका कुछ आया
नहीं है बट हां इन्होंने एक पीव रिपोर्ट
किया था जिसमें अगर इनका यह एक्सेप्ट हो
जाता है तो काफी अच्छी बाउंट लग सकती है
इनकी ठीक है उसके बाद यहां पे एक और
बाउंटीज से हमारे पेज को जब टैग किया गया
था तो हमें पता चला कि मरीज अरशद इन्होंने
एक रिपोर्ट किया था सेंसिटिव डाटा एंड
इनको 10 पॉइंट्स एंड 2 $ की बाउंट लगी हुई
थी एंड यह सारे रियल हैं यह कहीं से भी
कुछ फेक नहीं आप चाहे तो इनके प्रोफाइल पर
जाकर भी वेरीफाई कर सकते हैं जो इनका
पोस्ट है ठीक है आप इनकी प्रोफाइल वेरीफाई
कर सकते हैं व्हाट एवर हमने फिर पोस्ट भी
किया हुआ था कमेंट भी किया हुआ था
राइट ओके सो यू कैन यू कैन अंडरस्टैंड
गाइस आप समझ सकते हैं यू ऑल कैन
अंडरस्टैंड कि यहां पे क्या चीजें हो रही
है किस तरीके से चीजें काम कर कर रही है
किस तरीके से लोग धीरे-धीरे धीरे-धीरे
प्रोसेस कर रहे हैं आगे बढ़ रहे हैं एंड
जो लोग हमें टैग करते हैं हम उसको सिंपल
शेयर कर देते हैं
दैट्ची मेंट्स आप हमें टैग कीजिए एंड वी
विल शेयर इट एंड वी विल लाइक इट कमेंट इट
व्हाट एवर ठीक
है
चलिए ओके
ओके थैंक यू थैंक यू चलो
बढ़िया एक बार आप देख लीजिएगा शांके कौन
से फोटो में बात कर र मुझे ध्यान नहीं आ
रहा है फोटो की जो बात कर रहे हो इसकी बात
कर रहे हो क्या मुझे यहां पर यहां कहीं तो
लिखा तो नहीं है
शायद बट
स्टिल ठीक है मे बी कुछ भी हो सकता है व्ट
एवर आई डोंट नो बट जो जिनका मतलब लाइक
टैगिंग हुआ है एंड दोज हु आर टैगिंग वी आर
जस्ट पोस्टिंग इट राइट
ओके ठीक है आप एक बार वेरीफाई कर लीजिएगा
प्लीज एक बार जरूर वेरीफाई कर लीजिएगा
क्योंकि हम बस पोस्ट को शेयर कर रहे हैं
और कुछ नहीं आप आप भी टैग करेंगे वी विल
शेयर इट राइट बट यस प्लीज वेरीफाई हाउ कैन
वी नो द रियल आईपी एड्रेस व्हेन अ वेबसाइट
यूजिंग क्लाउड फ्लेर हर चीज का तरीका है
बेसिकली आप हर आप नॉर्मली इजली तो नहीं ले
सकते हैं लेकिन देयर आर सम मेथड्स वी विल
डिस्कस दैट ओरिजिन आईपी और आईपी एड्रेस जो
रिलीज होती है ओरिजिनल आईपी एड्रेस जो
आपका पता करने का एक तरीका होता है उसको
हम डिस्कस करेंगे देयर आर मल्टीपल वेज नॉट
अ 100% सक्सेसफुल वेज बट यस वी कैन ट्राई
एंड वी कैन गेट द आईपी एड्रेस ठीक है जैसे
मेरी वेबसाइट भी है क्लाउड फयर के पीछे है
बट जैसे मैं आपको एक
तरीका तरीका बता दूंगा आप उस पे जा सकते
हैं फिलहाल अभी जो हमारा टॉपिक है उसपे हम
आते हैं फोकस करते हैं एंड द टॉपिक इज अ
स्कैनिंग टारगेट्स फॉर ओपन पोर्ट्स एंड
सर्विसेस अब देखिए ये जो टॉपिक है वापस
अपने आप में बहुत ही ज्यादा एक्साइटिंग है
कैसे है मैं आपको समझाता हूं कि आज हमारा
जो मेन मोटो है वो क्या होने वाला है और
हम क्या करने वाले हैं ठीक है तो फर्स्ट
टॉक अबाउट द मोटो एंड देन वी विल डिस्कस
अदर थिंग्स ठीक है तो आज के सेशन में डे
15 में हम करने वाले हैं स्कैनिंग
टारगेट्स
की टारगेट्स को स्कैन हम क्यों करेंगे फॉर
पॉसिबल आईपी
एड्रेसस विथ ओपन
पोर्ट्स विथ ओपन पोर्ट्स एंड मोर
डोमस मोर डोमस फ्रॉम दोस आईपी
एड्रेस फ्रॉम दोज फ्रॉम दोज आईपी एड्रेसस
अब देखो अभी तक हमने क्या किया हमने अभी
तक क्या किया था हमने अभी तक डोमेन फाइंड
किए सब डोमेन फाइंड किए बट हम टारगेट के
या ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के आईपी एड्रेस को नहीं
फाइंड कर रहे हैं अब क्या होता है कई ऐसे
आईपी एड्रेसस भी आपको मिल सकते हैं एक
टारगेट डोमेन का जिस परे आप फर्द
न्यूमरेशन कर सकते हैं एंड उससे पॉसिबल
ओपन पोर्ट्स वाले आईपी एड्रेसस फाइंड कर
सकते हैं जिस पर किसी पर्टिकुलर आईपी
एड्रेस पर कोई पोर्ट ओपन हो कोई सर्विस चल
रही है अब यह देखो पोर्ट और सर्विस और ओपन
का क्या मतलब है यह भी मैं आपको समझाता
हूं देखो क्या होता है यह एक मान लो आपका
सर्वर है दिस इ सर्वर यह आपका क्लाइंट है
यह ब्राउजर आपका जनरली होता है क्लाइंट से
सर्वर को इस तरीके से रिक्वेस्ट जाती है
ठीक है सर्वर इस तरीके से क्या करता है
रेस्पों करता है तो क्लाइंट जब रिक्वेस्ट
करता है तो किसी पर्टिकुलर सर्विस के लिए
रिक्वेस्ट करता है ठीक है किसी भी
पर्टिकुलर सर्विस पे रिक्वेस्ट कर रहा
होता है जब आप ब्राउजर में कोई वेबसाइट
ओपन करते हैं तो वो एक किसी ना किसी
सर्विस पे ही चल रहा होता है एक प्रोटोकॉल
होता है जिस परे वह ऑपरेट कर रहा होता है
और वो प्रोटोकॉल कौन सा होता है वो
प्रोटोकॉल आपका होता
है एचटीटीपी या
एचटीटीपीएस राइट जिसपे कि आप सारी
वेबसाइट्स जो है ओपन करते यह प्रोटोकॉल है
उसी तरीके से एक प्रोटोकॉल और होता है
एफटीपी जो कि फाइल ट्रांसफर के लिए यूज
होता है एक एसएसए होता है सिक्योर रिमोट
लॉगिन के लिए यूज होता है एक नलेट होता है
अनसिक्योर रिमोट लॉगिन के लिए यूज होता है
ठीक है डीएनएस होता है जो कि डोमेन नेम
मैपिंग में जब डोमेन से आईपी में जो डोमेन
है उसकी आईपी को फाइंड करके लाने के लिए
डीएनएस आपका यूज होता है इस तरीके से और
बहुत सारे
प्रोटोकॉल जो जो यूज हो जैसे डीएचसीपी
प्रोटोकॉल है जो आपके आईपी को एलोकेट करता
है डायनेमिक ठीक है तो यह प्रोटोकॉल्स हैं
और यह सारे प्रोटोकॉल्स किसी ना किसी
पोर्ट पे काम कर रहे हैं ठीक है किसी ना
किसी पोर्ट पे काम कर रहे हैं जैसे
एसटीटीपी आपका 80 एटीपीएस 80 8443 इसम काम
करता है आपका एसएसए 22 एटीपीए 2021 तो ऐसे
सारे पोर्ट्स ये पोर्ट्स है ये सब के
पोर्ट्स है जिस पर ये ऑपरेट करते हैं हर
एक पोर्ट पे एक सर्विस रन हो रही हो हो
टोटल नंबर ऑफ पोर्ट्स कितने होते हैं एक
बताइए आप मुझे किसी को पता है टोटल नंबर
ऑफ पोर्ट्स लेट मी नो एनी वन हैव आईडिया
टोटल नंबर ऑफ पोर्ट्स कितने होते हैं किसी
को भी कुछ आईडिया है वेरी गुड इवनिंग टू
एवरीबॉडी लेट है कोई बात नहीं आप कंटिन्यू
कीजिए अभी जस्ट स्टार्ट हुआ है
सेशन बिल्कुल सही एब्सलूट करेक्ट अगर हम
टोटल नंबर ऑफ पोर्ट्स की बात करें टोटल
पोर्ट्स की बात करें तो 65
सॉरी 535 पोर्ट्स होते हैं जीरो छोड़ देते
हैं नहीं तो 36 आप बोल सकते हैं लेकिन
65500 35 यह पोर्ट्स होते हैं राइट ये
टोटल पोर्ट्स होते हैं इन्हीं पोर्ट्स में
यह सारी सर्विसेस लिस्टेड होती है सारे
सर्विसेस ऑपरेट कर रहे होते हैं अब मान लो
लेट्स सपोज मुझे कोई ऐसी सर्विस मिल
गई जिस परे पोर्ट ओपन है तो हम उससे
कनेक्ट कर पाएंगे हम यह देख पाएंगे कि उस
पर्टिकुलर टारगेट पे उस सर्विस का कौन सा
वर्जन चल रहा है ठीक है और वो वर्जन
एक्सप्लोइटेबल है कि नहीं
है ये हम देख सकते हैं सिंपल सा फंडा है
अभी मैं आपको एक मैं वीएम वेर ओपन कर लेता
हूं लेट मी सी इफ वी हैव मेट एक्स पलटेबल
देर या तो हमने वीएम वेर को ओपन कर लिया
है ठीक है और यहां पे हमारा काली है और
यहां पे हमारा मेटा स् पलटेबल है तो मैं
क्या करता हूं मैं सिंपल मैं यहां पे पहले
दे लेता हूं काली हमारे ब्रिज कौन से
नेटवर्क एडाप्टर प चल रहा है फिलहाल ये
नेट प चल रहा है ठीक है एंड व्हाट अबाउट
मेटा स्
पलटेबल दिस इ ब्रज दिस इज ब्रिज तो मैं
इसको भी नेट पर कर देता हूं को प्रॉब्लम
नहीं
है ओके लेट्स स्टार्ट
काली चलिए मैं काली को ओपन कर रहा हूं और
साइड में मैं मेटा पलटेबल जो हमारी
इंटेंशनली वरे मशीन है उसको भी स्टार्ट कर
रहा हं मैं आपको बस अभी एक ओवरव्यू दे रहा
हूं अभी मैं आपको बहुत डीप पढ़ाने वाला
हूं इस चीज के बारे में नेटवर्क स्कैनिंग
के और क्या इसका स्कोप है क्यों हमें यूज
पड़ेगा क्या हम टारगेट के और भी स्कोप को
बढ़ा सकते हैं नेटवर्क स्कैनिंग के थ्रू
तो बिल्कुल बढ़ा सकते हैं जब आप नेटवर्क
स्कैनिंग करते हो तो आप टारगेट के स्कोप
को डबल कर सकते हो आपके पास थाउजेंड्स ऑफ
आईपीस होंगी जिनको आप स्कैन कर सकते हो
पॉसिबल ओपन पोर्ट्स के लिए और ओपन पोर्ट
का मतलब यही है जो मैंने अभी आपको यहां पे
बताया कि अगर जैसे यहां पे मान लो मान लो
यहां पे एक एफटीपी पोर्ट है एक एफटीपी की
सर्विस चल रही है सर्वर पे इसका पोर्ट है
21 मान लो अब अगर यह 21 पोर्ट ओपन होता है
अगर यह 21
पोर्ट ओपन होता है तो हम इस 21 पोर्ट को
एक्सप्लोइट करने के लिए ट्राई कर सकते हैं
वी कैन एक्सप्लोइट एंड यह हमारा यह हमें
एक बाउंट लाके देगा
य हमें बाउंट लाके देगा वी विल हैव बाउंट
बाय डूइंग
दिस ऐसे ही एसएसए पोर्ट है अगर वह ओपन है
और एक्सप्लोइटेबल है पब्लिक एक्सप्लोइट
अवेलेबल है कोई एक्सप्लोइट अवेलेबल है कोई
वर्जन नंबर वैसा है जिसका एक्सप्लोइट
अवेलेबल है तो आप उसको एक्सप्लोइट कर सकते
एक्सेस गेन करने की कोशिश कर सकते हो न यू
डिड दैट यू गेट अब बाउंट 100% शर यह चीज
होती है ठीक है चलिए अब
देखिए ओके ग्रेट कोई बात नहीं कोई इशू
नहीं है यहां पे मिट स् पलटेबल में हम
लॉगइन कर लेते हैं एंड फॉर दैट एमएसएफ
एडमिन इज द यूजर नेम एंड एमएसएफ एडमिन इज
द पासवर्ड आई होप मैंने आपको पहले बोला था
य मैं टस्ट पलटेबल के बारे में यहां मैं
काली में लॉग इन कर लेता हूं लेट मी लॉग
इन विद द काली एंड वी मस्ट हैव गट द आईपी
एड्रेस हियर सो व्हाट आईपी एड्रेस वी गॉट
हियर लेट्स चेक सो इट्स आईएफ
कॉन्फिडो यह वाली हमें आ आई एडस 198 11130
1130 है तो हम पिन करके एक बार देख लेते
हैं पिंग
192.168
11110 एंड यस इट्स पिंग द मशीन हमारे जो
मशीन है उसको पिंग कर रहा है जो मेटा
स्टेबल है राइट तो अब जो है गाइस देखो
य बड़ा कर देता हूं मैं इसको अब मैं क्या
करूंगा हमारा काम क्या है आईपीस को कलेक्ट
करना होस्ट्स को आईपीस को होस्ट के आईपीस
को कलेक्ट करना और उसपे हमें एन मैप चला
के यह देखना है कि कौन-कौन सी पोर्ट्स ओपन
है और सर्विसेस कौन-कौन से जो है वो चल
रहे हैं बेसिकली हम सर्विसेस के लिए ए मैप
का यूज़ करेंगे पोर्ट्स ओपन करने ओपन चेक
करने के लिए या जो भी चीजें करने के लिए
हम दूसरे टूल्स का यूज़ करेंगे जो बहुत
ज्यादा फास्ट है एज कंपेयर टू एम एम इज अ
वेरी स्लो टूल अगर मैं बात करूं ए मैप की
तो बहुत स्लो काम करता है ठीक है ड्यू टू
सम अदर टेक्निकल फैक्टर्स इट ऑपरेट्स वेरी
स्लो बट इस इस का अल्टरनेटिव हम यूज करने
वाले हैं फॉर फास्ट स्कैनिंग अब
देखिए क्या कर सकता है एक अटैकर एक हैकर
के पर्सपेक्टिव से अगर हम सोचे तो वह क्या
कर सकता है हालांकि हम यह सारी चीजें
एजुकेशनल परपस के लिए सीखते हैं और उसी के
लिए मैं यह सीरीज बनाता हूं ताकि आपको बक
बाउंट की नॉलेज हो ताकि आपको वीपीटी की
नॉलेज हो वनबिल असेसमेंट एंड पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग की नॉलेज हो एंड आप इस फील्ड में
इस डोमेन में कहीं जाए और अच्छा कुछ कर
पाए राइट इसमें करियर बना पाए सो अब हम
यहां पे एमफ कमांड एक चला सिंपल सा एक
सिंपल ए मैप कमांड चलाएंगे ठीक है और यहां
पे हम आईपी देंगे हमारे वल्नरेबल मशीन का
तो हमने इसको आईपी दिया यहां
पे और एंटर किया जैसे ही हमने एंटर किया
इसने हमें बताया कि इस पर्टिकुलर मशीन पे
या होस्ट पे या सर्वर पे कौन-कौन सी पोर्ट
जो है वह ओपन है कौन-कौन सी सर्विस चल रही
है तो आप देख सकते हैं पोर्ट 21 भी ओपन है
22 भी बहुत सारे पोर्ट्स ओपन है क्योंकि
यह इंटेंशनली वल्नरेबल है तो जानबूझ के
पोर्ट ओपन ही रखे गए हैं बट रियल जब आप
टारगेट पे आएंगे तो ये इंटेंशनली वल्नरेबल
पोर्ट्स आपको नहीं दिखेंगे वहां पे बहुत
मुश्किल से आपको ओपन पोर्ट्स मिलने वाले
हैं और अगर मिलते हैं तो ये आपकी जीत होती
है वहां पे ठीक है एंड अ यू मस्ट गो फॉर
सम एक्सप्लोइट्स तो अब यहां पे मुझे
सर्विसेस की लिस्ट तो मिल गई कि इस
पर्टिकुलर पोर्ट पे कौन सी सर्विस चल रही
है एफटीपी एसएसए लेट एएमटीपी डोमेन आप देख
सकते हैं यहां पे सारा मिल गया बट हमें अब
इसकी वर्जन डिटेल्स भी चाहिए
क्यों चाहिए उसके बारे में मैं बताऊंगा तो
ए मैप की एक चीट शीट है जो मैं प पर अपलोड
कर दूंगा आपके लिए बट फिलहाल मैं आपको
यहां पर दिखा देता
हूं यहां पर चीट शीट्स है इनमें ए मैप की
पूरी लिस्ट आपकी बनाई गई है कैसे आपको एप
यूज करना है तो इसके हम सर्विस वाले
सेक्शन में आते हैं यहां पे नीचे आ जाते
हैं सर्विस एंड वर्जन डिटेक्शन में तो
यहां पे हान एसवी करके एक स्विच है या एक
आर्गुमेंट एक ऑप्शन है क्या होता है
अटेम्प्ट्स टू डिटरमाइंड द वर्जन ऑफ द
सर्विस रनिंग ऑन द पोर्ट ठीक
कौन सी वर्जन सर्विस की रन हो रही है तो
हमें यही तो अभी फाइंड करना है ना तो हम
क्या करेंगे यहां पर हाइन एवी ये एक स्विच
लगा देंगे ट्स इट हम इसको मैं इसको यहां
पर करके और एंटर कर देता हूं ठीक है अब
देखिए जस्ट
वेट या
या
ठीक है अब यहां पर हमने जैसे ही ए मैप का
तुम लोग अ तुम लोग के चैट्स बहुत मजेदार
होते हैं यार तुम लोग के चैट्स में मतलब
थोड़ा इधर देखो ध्यान दो हमने जैसे ही एक
कमांड लगाया हाइन एसवी अब यहां पर हमें
सर्विस तो दिखाई साथ में उसके वर्जन भी
देख पा रहे हैं यह तो हमने वर्जन लिस्टिंग
कर दी अब अब करंट वर्जन यह देखिए एफटीपी
पोर्ट ओपन है इसका एक वर्जन क्या है व एस
एफटीपीडी
2.3.4 यह हमें पता चला बट करंट एफटीपीडी
का वर्जन यह नहीं है यह ओल्ड वर्जन
एफटीपीडी सर्विस है और जब भी कोई वर्जन
ओल्ड वर्जन सर्विस यूज हो रही होती किसी
सर्वर पर किसी मशीन पे तो वह मोस्ट
प्रोबेबली एक्सप्लोइटेबल होती है एंड
उसमें कोई ना कोई वलन बिलिटी होती है
पास्ट में पाई जाती है या पाई गई है जिसको
आप ट्राई कर सकते एक्सप्लोइट करने का सेम
चीज यहां जा रही है आपकी सेम चीज यहां
अप्लाई हो रही है अब मैं क्या करूंगा इस
पर्टिकुलर वर्जन के लिए ट्राई करूंगा इस
पर्टिकुलर वर्जन के लिए ट्राई करूंगा कि
कुछ अवेलेबल है क्या तो मैं यहां पे दो दो
तरीके से एक तो मैं यहां से डायरेक्टली
यहां से मैं एक तो यूज कर सकता हूं क्या
सर्च स् पलट एंड यहां पे मैं वोह लिस्ट कर
दूंगा जो मेरा पर्टिकुलर वर्जन के लिए मैं
एक्सप्लोइट सर्च कर रहा हूं और मैं एंटर
कर दूंगा अगर कोई पर्टिकुलर अ एक्सप्लोइट
अवेलेबल है सर्च सर्च पट के डेटाबेस में
तो आपको यहां पर देखने को मिल जाएगा तो आप
देख रहे हैं यहां पर कि दो यहां पर
एक्सप्लोइट्स अवेलेबल है एक सिंपल
एक्सप्लोइट अवेलेबल है पाइथन की और एक
मेटा एक्सप्लोइट की एक्सप्लोइट अवेलेबल है
आपके पास ठीक है यानी कि एक्सप्लोइट से
अवेलेबल है यानी कि आप इसको मेटा
एक्सप्लोइट से एक्सप्लोइट कर सकते हो सेम
चीज हम ग पे भी ट्राई कर सकते हैं कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं है यू कैन जस्ट गो टू ग एंड
यू कैन सर्च
सिंपल
यू कैन सर्च दिस पर्टिकुलर वीएस एफटीपीडी
वर्जन एंड यहां पर आगे एक्सप्लोइट लिख
देना है यहां पे आपको
एक्सप्लोइट लिख देना है जैसे ही आप एंटर
करेंगे आपको यहां बहुत सारे रिजल्ट्स
मिलेंगे आप इन रिजल्ट्स को टॉप फाइव
रिजल्ट्स को ओपन कर सकते हैं एंड आपको
इसके एक्सप्लोइट की डिटेल मिल जाएगी कि
कोई पब्लिकली नोन एक्सप्लोइट है या नहीं
है इस पर्टिकुलर वर्जन में तो आपको यहां
पर दिख रहा है वस एटी 2.3.4 में कमांड
एग्जीक्यूशन जो बैकडोर कमांड एग्जीक्यूशन
की वनबिल है वो यहां पे इसके अंदर है एंड
यह एक मेटा एक्सप्लोइट मॉड्यूल के थ्रू आप
इसको एग्जीक्यूट कर सकते हैं अभी हम इसको
एग्जीक्यूट नहीं करने जा रहे हैं क्योंकि
अभी फिलहाल नीड नहीं है बट एट अ टाइम मैं
इसको आपको एग्जीक्यूट करके भी दिखाऊंगा कि
एक्चुअली क्या होता है यू कैन सिंपली हैक
इनटू द एफटीपी प्रोटोकॉल ऑफ दैट पर्टिकुलर
टारगेट और जब इतना आपने कर तो यह बहुत
ज्यादा हो गया काफी हो गया कि टू रिपोर्ट
इट फॉर द पॉसिबल बग और व बिलिटी एंड आपको
बाउंट मिलेगी वहां लगेगी कोई प्रॉब्लम
नहीं है तो इस तरीके से यह हम काम करने
वाले हैं तो हमारा मेन मोटो क्या था मैं
इसको अब यहां पर बंद कर देता हूं कि इसकी
हमें रिक्वायरमेंट है नहीं बेसिकली तो
हमारा यहां पर मोटो क्या है मोटो अब क्या
है यहां
पर मोटो टू
कलेक्ट एज मेनी आईपी एड्रेसस ऑफ अ
टारगेट कलेक्ट कर लिया डू अ पोर्ट
स्कैन डू अ रिवर्स
डीएनएस रिवर्स डीएनएस क्या होता है वह भी
मैं आपको बताऊंगा रिवर्स डीएनएस का मतलब
ज्यादा टेंशन नहीं लेना है मैं आपको बहुत
इजली समझा दूंगा कि रिवर्स डीएनएस क्या
होता है उसके बाद फोर
में फाइंड सम जूसी
इंफो और बग
ठीक है यहां पे डू अ पोर्ट स्कैन एंड
फाइंड
सर्विसेस एंड ओपन
पोर्ट्स ओपन पोर्ट्स एंड लुक फॉर लुक फॉर
पॉसिबल बग्स ठीक है तो वहां पे हम यह सारी
चीजें करने वाले हैं यह सारी चीजें अब
रिवर्स डीएनएस का मतलब क्या होता है यह भी
मैं आपको समझा देता हूं देखो रिवर्स
डीएनएस का मतलब होता है डीएनएस का उल्टा
सीधा-सीधा एकदम उल्टा चलो मैं इसको अभी
क्लोज कर देता हूं इट्स नॉट रिक्वायर्ड
करेंटली ठीक है मैं यहां पर
[संगीत]
इसको इसको थोड़ा सा
मैं बड़ा कर देता हूं यहां
पर हा रिवर्स डीएनएस का क्या मतलब होता है
इसको मैं डिलीट ही करता हूं चलो रिवर्स
डीएनएस का देखो डीएनएस का क्या काम होता
है डीएन एस इसका क्या काम होता है जो अगर
आपका डोमेन है एी सीड कॉ मान लो तो तो
इसकी आईपी आपको लाकर यह देता है क्योंकि
हमें ब्राउजर में जब हम टाइप करते हैं
जैसे हम ब्राउजर में ब्राउजर में टाइप कर
रहे हैं टेस्ला कॉ तो ब्राउजर को यानी कि
हमारे जो हमारी जो ब्राउजर है भैया इसको
टेस्ला से मतलब नहीं है नहीं पता इसको तो
जैसे ही हम एंटर करते हैं हमारा डीएनएस
यहां पर काम करना शुरू करता है और डीएनएस
इसकी आईपी खोज के लाता है और ब्राउजर फिर
उस आईपी से कनेक्ट करके उस सर्वर तक
पहुंचता है जो पर्टिकुलर आईपी होती है अब
इसी में अगर हम रिवर्स डीएनएस की बात करते
हैं व्हेन वी वी आर टॉकिंग अबाउट
रिवर्स
डीएनएस जब हम रिवर्स डीएनएस की बात करते
हैं तो यहां अब उल्टा हो जाता है आईपी से
हमें क्या
मिलेगा डोमेन मिलेगा हमारे पास एक आईपी है
उससे डोमेन मिलेगा तो हम यही काम करने
वाले हैं यहां पे एज मेनी आईपी एड्रेस से
जितने आईपी एड्रेस मिलेंगे उसको हम लेकर
आएंगे और ट्राई करेंगे उससे पॉसिबल और भी
डोमेंस फाइंड करने का और जब डोमेन हमारे
पास आ गया तो हम उस पर्टिकुलर डोमेन के
लिए भी एन मैप कर सकते हैं हम उस
पर्टिकुलर डोमेन पे ब्रूट फोर्स कर सकते
हैं डायरेक्टरी ब्रूट फोर्सिंग कर सकते
हैं और जितने भी टाइप ऑफ वल एबिलिटीज है
हम उसपे अप्लाई कर सकते हैं तो हमारा
स्कैन स्कोप जो है ना वो बहुत ज्यादा
इंक्रीज हो जाएगा हमारा स्कैन सर्फेस
हमारा स्कोप सरफेस बहुत ज्यादा इंक्रीज हो
जाएगा तो वनबिल मिलने के चांसेस भी आपके
इंक्रीज हो जाएंगे इतने समझने में आप में
से किसी को कोई दिक्कत आई तो मुझे
बताइए प्लीज लेट मी
नो बिल्कुल बिल्कुल सीवीज ढूंढ सकते हैं
कोई दिक्कत नहीं आएंगे हम सीवीज वाले पोट
पोशन प भी आएंगे बहुत सारी चीजें कर सकते
हैं
आप बट हम बिल्कुल एकदम बिगनर लेवल से
करेंगे जो भी करेंगे ताकि जिनको कुछ नहीं
पता उनको भी पता चले जिनको ऑलरेडी पता है
तो उनके लिए जब यह थोड़ा आगे बढ़ जाए तब
आप उसमें
अपना कंट्रीब्यूशन दे सकते हैं आप सीख
सकते हैं बाकी तो बिल्कुल बिगनर लेवल से
ही हम चलेंगे ताकि बिल्कुल जो जिसको कुछ
नहीं पता उसके लिए ही है ये सीरीज राइट
थोड़ा सा बस वेट कीजिएगा एंड वी विल गेट
बैक टू दैट थिंग ओके ऑल क्लियर ऑल क्लियर
ओके ठीक है चलिए इतना समझ में आ गया अब
देखिए यहां
पे ठीक है चलिए अब मैं यहां पे जो बात कर
रहा हूं टारगेट की तो हम टारगेट कोई सा भी
ले सकते हैं इट टोटली इट्स अ अप टू अस कि
टारगेट हम कौन सा ले जैसे हम बक क्राउड
में चलते हैं बक क्राउड से कोई टारगेट ले
सकते हैं व्हाट एवर टारगेट यू वांट यू कैन
टेक दैट बट जब हम आईपी एड्रेसस फाइंड करना
चाहते हैं इसका मतलब हम बात कर रहे एक
बड़े टारगेट के बारे में छोटे टारगेट के
बारे में हम बिल्कुल भी बात नहीं कर रहे
हैं वी विल गेट नथिंग ऑन अ स्मॉलर
टारगेट स्मॉलर टारगेट्स में आईपी ब्लॉक्स
ब्लॉक्स नहीं होंगी उतनी उतनी आईपी
एड्रेसस दे वेर नॉट यूटिलाइजिंग
बट बड़ी टारगेट होगी तभी वह बहुत बड़ा
आईपी रेंज यूटिलाइज करते हैं एंड तभी हम
उसको यूज कर सकते हैं एज अ टारगेट जैसे कि
टेस्ला को यूज कर सकते हैं
[संगीत]
हम सर्च करते हैं टेस्ला लेट्स सपोज यहां
पर हमने टेस्ला सर्च किया तो हमें एक एसएन
नंबर मिल जाता है ठीक है अब हम यहां सर्च
करते हैं
flipkart.com भी कर देता हूं लेट्स
सपोज नो इंफॉर्मेशन फेस्ट फ्रॉम हियर
बिकॉज ये बहुत छोटी सी साइट्स है ये आपको
लग रहा होगा इंडिया में बहुत ज्यादा
पॉपुलर है इसका मतलब मतलब ये नहीं कि बहुत
बड़ी साइट ये सिर्फ इंडिया इंडिया में
पॉपुलर इंडिया की वेबसाइट है बहुत छोटी सी
साइट है इनका कोई बहुत बड़ा नेटवर्क ब्लॉक
रेंज नहीं होगा नेटवर्क ब्लॉक्स नहीं है
इनके पास आईपी रेंजेस नहीं है इनके पास तो
आपको इन टारगेट को फिर छोड़ देना पड़ेगा
तो आपको बड़े टारगेट की तरफ चलना पड़ेगा
सम बिगर टारगेट जैसे मान लो
एल एल पे एंटर कर देते हैं यू विल गेट सम
लाइक यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं नेटवर्क
रेंजेस आपको मिल रहा है यहां पे ये सारे
नेटवर्क रेंजेस आपको मिल रहे हैं यहां पे
ये देखिए ये नेटवर्क रेंजेस है ये
ऑर्गेनाइजेशंस है यहां पे जो के हैं यहां
पे पर्टिकुलर ऑर्गेनाइजेशंस यहां पे यह
कस्टमर्स के यह सारी चीजें ठीक है यू गेट
अ लॉट ऑफ इंफो फ्रॉम
हियर ओके अब इसी तरीके से लाइक काइंड ऑफ
चलिए अब मैं यहां पे चलता हूं बग हंटिंग
में एंड यहां चलते रेकन पे एंड लेट्स ओपन
दिस
वन ठीक है एंड यहां पे मैं एल सर्च करता
हूं और एंटर करता हूं तो यहां पे आपको
जैसे ही आपने एल सर्च किया यहां पे तो
आपको इसका एस नंबर दिख जाएगा कितने
apple.com सपोर्ट सिस्टम स्ट कंट्रोल इज
इन यूनाइटेड स्टेट्स और यहां पे आप ग्राफ
ग्राफ देख स सकते वर्जन फ का कितना
कॉम्प्लेक्टेड आपको यहां पे दिख जाएगा एंड
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन में आपको एल आईसी दिख जाएगी
ठीक है तो हम बात करें हैं बड़े टारगेट्स
की बड़े टारगेट की बात नहीं करेंगे तो फिर
कोई फायदा नहीं है एंड वी विल गेट नथिंग
आउट ऑफ आवर स्कैनिंग पार्ट ठीक है चलिए तो
अब हम
हम मूव करेंगे दूसरे पर अगर जाना चाहते
हैं तो एक और एल आई एनसी करके यहां पर एक
और है जिसकी एसएन नंबर 6185 तो दो एसएन
नंबर्स आपको हमारे पास मिल रहे हैं वी कैन
गो विद दिस राइट ठीक है तो हा
ट्रेनिंग का मैंने कोई लिमिट नहीं रखा है
एंड यह ट्रेनिंग एटलीस्ट छ महीना तो
चलेगा एटलीस्ट उसके आगे भी चलेगा फिर
एडवांस और भी एडवांस चीजें आनी शुरू हो
जाएंगी बहुत ही एडवांस चीजें आनी हो
जाएंगी मतलब हर एक चीज स्क्रिप्टिंग से
लेकर ऑटोमेशन से लेके कुछ ऐसी लेवल के जो
आप बेसिकली यू कैन अज्यू लाइक ओससीपी लेवल
के थिंग्स यहां पे आपको जो वेब पेन
टेस्टिंग में की रिक्वायरमेंट है वो आपकी
आनी शुरू हो जाएगी एंड वो चलती रहेगी एंड
नहीं है ठीक
है चलिए तो यह एस नंबर से हमें टारगेट
चाहिए तो अब हम एक टारगेट को चूज कर लेते
हैं व्हाट एवर टारगेट वी वांट वी कैन चूज
द टारगेट ठीक है चलिए तो यहां पे हमें ए
कुछ मिला है क्या नहीं मिला यहां पे
apple.com करके एक बार चेक कर लेते हैं इफ
यू आर गेटिंग कुछ भी नहीं है डायरेक्ट एल
से ही कर लेंगे एल वहां से भी कर लेे ठीक
है हां
जी ओके चलिए आ जाते हैं यहां
पे ओके अब मैं यहां पर आपको एक छोटा सा
एग्जांपल प्रैक्टिकल एग्जांपल दिखाता हूं
बहुत ही शानदार एक प्रैक्टिकल एग्जांपल
दिखाता हूं ठीक है जो कि आपको मजा आएगा
मतलब समझने में आपको हेल्प करेगा हालांकि
यह मैं बाद में भी बता सकता था बट मैं
आपको अभी इसलिए बता रहा हूं ताकि आपको
थोड़ा सा समझ में आ ठीक है
दैट्ची कोई दिक्कत नहीं है अब मैं क्या
करता हूं मैं सडन प चलता हूं सडन पे ठीक
है आप सबको पता है ना सडन के बारे
में प्रो लेवल बग हंटर तो आप बनोगे इस बात
की पूरी गारंटी है 100% निखिल डिपेंड करता
है आप किस तरी किस तरीके से टेक ऑन कर रहे
हो इस ट्रेनिंग के ऊपर मैं अपना बेस्ट
दूंगा आप अगर अपना बेस्ट दोगे तो प्रो से
भी बड़े लेवल के बन सकते हो बग बाउंट हंटर
कोई बड़ी बात नहीं वो सब सब आपके ऊपर
डिपेंड करता है आपकी मेहनत और आपकी
एक्सप्लोरेशन पावर के ऊपर डिपेंड करता है
मैं तो आपको गाइड करूंगा बस उससे ज्यादा
क्या करूंगा मैं आपको आई कैन जस्ट गाइड यू
आई कैन प्रोवाइड यू मोर सोफिस्टिकेटेड
कंटेंट्स मोर वैल्युएबल कंटेंट्स बाकी
उसको ढालना है उसको एक तरीके से अरेंज वे
में लेके चलने का और मेहनत करने का
कंसिस्टेंसी डेडिकेशन वो आपके हाथों में
वो आप जितना जो करेगा उसको वैसा ही रिजल्ट
मिलेगा एज सिंपल एज दैट ठीक
है अब सडन में मैं यहां पे एक डॉर्क यूज़
करता हूं क्या मैं डॉर्क यूज़ करूंगा
देखिए हां सडन में मैं क्या डॉर्क यूज़
करूंगा यहां पे देखिए मैं यहां पे एसए
नंबर से फाइंड करने की कोशिश करता हूं
जैसे मेरे पास एसएन नंबर है एंड मैं यहां
पे एसए नंबर कौन सा यूज़ कर रहा हूं 39
4161 जो कि किसका है एसए नंबर मैं आपको
दिखा देता हूं फिर से एक
बार हुज एसए नंबर इज दिस मैं यहां पे सर्च
करता हूं एंड यू विल गेट tesla.svs ठीक है
यह टेस्ला का एसन नंबर है तो हम टेस्ला का
एसन नंबर जो है उस परे हमने क्या किया सडन
पर ये एक हमारा डॉर किया एंड हम इसको सर्च
करते हैं जैसे हम सर्च करेंगे हमें कुछ
रिजल्ट्स मिलने चाहिए लेट्स सी एंड यू सॉ
कि हमें सेवन रिजल्ट्स मिले
ओनली हम हमें सेवन रिजल्ट्स मिले अब इन
सेवन रिजल्ट में कुछ काम का है क्या जैसे
वेलकम टू
एनज नथिंग मच राही पेज
राही अ व सॉरी बट साइड टेंपरली आउट ऑफ
सर्विस आउट ऑफ सर्विस है ठीक है वेलकम टू
एजिंग अगेन एंजन का है एंड ओके टेस्ट राही
पेज यह भी अवेलेबल नहीं होगा शायद लेट्स
सी लेट्स सी व्हाट इज देयर ऑन दिस पेज
चलिए ओपन होता है यहां पे एक एक्सवे
सिक्योर ट्रांसपोर्ट टेस्ला मोटर्स का एक
पेज है देखिए यहां पे ये लॉगइन पेज है एक
ओके ओके ये देखिए दिस इज अ लॉगइन पेज दैट
वी गट हियर एंड यह लॉगिन पेज जैसे आपने
क्या किया एस नंबर से आपने सर्विसेस फाइंड
की यहां पे हमें एक लॉगिन पेज मिल गया अब
ये लॉगिन पेज पे हम ट्राई कर सकते हैं
डिफॉल्ट यूजर नेम पासवर्ड जैसे
एडमिन पासवर्ड या फिर
एडमिन
रूट
रूट ऐसे मतलब आप डिफॉल्ट लॉगिन ट्राई कर
सकते हैं इफ यू वांट यू कैन ट्राई द
डिफॉल्ट लॉगिन ठीक है यहां पे कुछ नहीं
ओपन हुआ अब या फिर हम पासवर्ड जैसे हमें
ऐसे आईपी एड्रेसस भी मिल जाएंगे जहां पे
लॉगइन पेजेस आपको मिलेंगे जब आप स्कैनिंग
कर रहे होंगे तो स्कैनिंग से इसलिए बहुत
ज्यादा बेनिफिट बेनिफिट आपको मिलेगा बहुत
कुछ मिल सकता है आपको अब ऐसे लॉगिन पेज प
आप ब्रूट फोर्स भी कर सकते हैं ब्रूट
फोर्स करने आता है सबको एवरी बडी नो ब्रूट
फोर्स हाउ टू डू ब्रूट फोर्स लॉगइन पेजेस
पे प्लीज बताइए मुझे ब्रूट फोर्स आप करना
आता है आप लोगों
को लॉगिन पेजेस
पे प्लीज लेट मी नो
गाइस नो नो नो नो नो
55 लोग हैं बट अगर आप में से रिप्लाई
सिर्फ 10 लोगों का आएगा तो मैं तो मूव ऑन
कर जाऊंगा बट मैक्सिमम लोगों का आएगा तो
मैं उसको
बताऊंगा बब से बब से हां बब से कर सकते
हैं
ओके
ओके ठीक
है
हां बफ शूट से होता है ठीक है बब सूट से
आप कर सकते हैं थोड़ा इजी हो
जाएगा अच्छा ठीक है चलिए मैं यहां पे आपको
एक चीज मैं एक बार ट्राई आपको एक बार मैं
आपको दिखा देता हूं थोड़ा सा ओवरव्यू दे
देता हूं किस तरीके से आप पॉसिबली ट्राई
कर सकते हैं हाउ यू कैन ट्राई पॉसिबल
पॉसिबली तो हम यहां पे क्या करते हैं यहां
पे एक यूजर नेम पासवर्ड की एक लिस्ट
डाउनलोड कर लेते हैं ठीक है लाइक अ
[संगीत]
कॉमन यूजर नेम
लिस्ट लेट्स सी
[संगीत]
हियर यह रही कॉमन यूजर नेम
अ ओनली एडमिन नहीं है क्या इसमें
यह कौन सा चीज है भाई ओनली एडमिन
नहीं ओके लीव इट लेट्स सी कॉमन एडमिन बेस
डिफॉल्ट यूजर
नेम देखते य पे या सो यहां पर है बहुत
सारी लिस्ट है यहां से आप डाउनलोड कर सकते
कोई सा भी यूजर लिस्ट यूजर नेम का लिस्ट
आप डाउनलोड कर लीजिए ठीक है एफफ यूफ से कर
सकते हैं कहीं से भी कर सकते हैं कोई
दिक्कत नहीं मैं आपको बहुत इजी तरीका
बताता हूं एक
बार यह लिस्ट है ठीक है
हटाओ यूज़र नेम लिस्ट गेट
हब यह यूज़र नेम की एक शॉर्ट यूजरनेम
लिस्ट है थोड़ी छोटी सी है अ विल यू कैन
टेक इट और थोड़ी सी यह बड़ी है 828 तो
इतना ज्यादा तो नहीं करने वाले हैं अ टॉप
यूज़र नेम शॉर्टलिस्ट यह वाली कर लेते हैं
शॉर्ट लिस्ट को यूज कर लेते हैं कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं है पासवर्ड को यूज कर लेंगे
अलग-अलग तरीके से यहां पे एंड कुछ यूजर
लिस्ट यहां प हम डाउनलोड करले यहां पे मैं
डाउनलोड कर लेता हूं इसको इस फाइल को एंड
देन हम कर सकते
हैं कॉमन पासवर्ड वर्ड लिस्ट ठीक है तो
पासवर्ड की भी वर्ड लिस्ट जो है डाउनलोड
कर लेते हैं राइट सेक लिस्ट से भी कर सकते
हैं एंड यहां से भी कर सकते हैं ये कॉमन
पासवर्ड हो गया 1000 लाइंस के एंड ये
कितने हैं ये भी ये 10000 लाइंस है एंड यह
है 1000 लाइंस तो यह बहुत बड़ी है तो इसको
ही डाउनलोड कर लेते हैं यहां पे तो एक
यूजर नेम एंड एक पासवर्ड फाइल आपकी होनी
चाहिए दैट्ची है दोनों फाइल्स अब हम यहां
पे गाइज व्हाट वी विल डू अ हम एक बार
ट्राई कर लेते हैं ठीक है तो हम यहां पे
क्या करेंगे बब शूट को कॉन्फ़िगर कर लेंगे
तो सेटिंग में चलते हैं एंड यहां पे अ
पहले मैं बब शूट को ओपन कर लेता हूं लेट्स
अ ओपन द बब शूट हियर लेट्स ओपन द बॉब शोट
लेट्स लोड लेट्स रन लेट्स वेट चलिए
भाई तुम किसी भी टूल से कर लो मैं बफ शूट
से बता रहा हूं बहुत सारे और तरीके हैं
ब्रूट फोर्स करने के जी हां बहुत सारे
तरीके यू कैन यूज एफफ य कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं
है यहां प्रॉक्सी ऑफ कर देते हैं मैं इसको
पहले बॉब शूट को कॉन्फिनेक्स में अगेन मैं
यहां पर थोड़ा सा नेटवर्क सेटिंग जो है वो
कर लेते
हैं ब नेटवर्क सेटिंग को मैनल प्रॉक्सी कर
लीजिएगा देन हम यहां पर टारगेट वाली पेज
पर आ जाते हैं यह जो टारगेट पेज है हमारा
राइट एंड इंटरसेप्ट को ऑन कर लेते हैं एंड
यहां पे कुछ भी यूजर नेम पासवर्ड यहां पे
फिलहाल के लिए हम यहां पे लॉगिन करते हैं
एडमिन एडमिन टू एंड यहां पे हम लॉगिन करते
हैं एंड इट मस्ट बी कैप्चरड हियर तो यहां
पे कैप्चर होगा ये फॉरवर्ड कर लेते हैं
एंड लेट्स फॉरवर्ड इट लेट्स फॉरवर्ड इट
अ एज इट
वर्किंग
ओके एक्सेप्ट द रिस्क एंड कंटिन्यू कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं है यहां पे आ चुका है यहां
पे यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं एक यूजर नेम
एडमिन एंड पासवर्ड एडमिन यह इस तरीके से आ
चुका है यहां पे अब इसको क्या आप कर सकते
हो इंट्रूडर को भेज सकते हो सेंड टू
इंट्रूडर एंड
दैट्ची इसको एंड यह जो यूजर है ना यहां पे
यूजर एडमिन तो आप ये यूजर एडमिन पहले ना
आपको अटैक टाइप को चेंज करना पड़ेगा यहां
पे अटैक टाइप को चेंज करना पड़ेगा राइट
थोड़ा सा यहां पे आप क्लस्टर बम यूज कर
सकते हैं एंड यहां पे अब जो है आप एडमिन
को यहां सेलेक्ट कीजिए यहां पे आप ऐड कर
दीजिए पासवर्ड को सेलेक्ट कीजिए एंड यहां
पे जहां पे आप पेलोड यूज करना चाहते हैं
उसको सेलेक्ट करना है और यहां पे ऐड कर
देना है पॉइंटर ठीक है हमने ऐड कर दिया
यहां पे पोजीशंस ऐड कर दिया यहां पे यूजर
नेम यूजर और पासवर्ड के लिए दोनों पोजीशंस
को हमने ऐड कर दिया यानी यह दो पोजीशंस जो
है वो पलट के अकॉर्डिंग चेंज आप कर सकते
हो इंट्रूडर का यही फायदा है अगर आपने बब
शूट वाली वीडियो नहीं देखी है तो यू शुड
डेफिनेटली वच द वीडियो ऑफ आर डेनिक्स ठीक
है अगर आपने अब तक नहीं देखा है तो प्लीज
देखिएगा बब शूट के बारे में अगर नॉलेज
नहीं है तो मैंने इसके ऊपर ऑलरेडी क्लासेस
दे रखी हैं एंड इसलिए मैं बोलता हूं हर एक
क्लास हर एक वीडियो बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट है बग
बाउंट सीरीज की वो प्लीज देखिएगा आप लाइव
सेक्शन में जब
जाएंगे यहां पे नीचे आएंगे यहां पे नीचे
आएंगे यहां पे नीचे आएंगे यहां पे तो यहां
बब शूट इन डेप्थ ट्यूटोरियल पौने घंटे का
लगभग वीडियो है आप इसको जरूर देख लीजिएगा
आपको समझ में आ
जाएगा ठीक है अब यहां पे क्लस्टर बॉम हमने
यूज कर लिया अब यहां पे पे लोट्स पे आएंगे
पे लोट्स पे आप आएंगे तो अब क्या है
पेलोड्स में पेलोड वन और पेलोड टू दो आपको
दिख रहा होगा तो पेलोड वन के लिए आप
सेपरेट सेट कर सकते हैं पेलोड वन कौन सा
आपका यूजर और पेलो टू आपका पासवर्ड रहेगा
तो पेलोड्स पे आएंगे सिंपल लिस्ट में आ
जाएंगे एंड यहां पे लिस्ट लोड कर देंगे
यूजर नेम ली ठीक है तो यहां पर मैं
डाउनलोडस पर चल देता हूं लेट्स गो टू
डाउनलोड्स एंड लेट्स फाइंड द यूजर नेम
यूजरनेम
फाइल डटी एक्सटी थी ना सो लेट्स फाइंड द
यूजर
नेम ओके लेट्स सी क्या नाम था टॉप यूजर
नेम ठीक है तो टॉप यूजरनेम ड शटी एक्सटी
इसको ओपन कर लेते एंड यहां पे हमने लिस्ट
में डाल दिया है एंड अब हम सेलेक्ट करेंगे
क्या यहां पे पेलो टू एंड देन हम यहां पे
सिंपल लिस्ट लोड करेंगे एंड यहां पे इसकी
फाइल नेम क्या थी अ 10k मोस्ट ठीक है ना
तो 10k मोस्ट कॉमन पासवर्ड इसको हम ओपन कर
लेंगे तो यहां पे पासवर्ड लिस्ट ऐड कर
दिया ठीक है तो ऑलमोस्ट यहां पे पेलोड
10000 पेलोड इसके हैं यूजर नेम के पासवर्ड
के और 17 आपके यूजर नेम के हैं एंड
[संगीत]
दैट्ची हैं जस्ट क्लिक ऑन स्टार्ट अटैक
एंड इट शुड बी वर्किंग राइट तो अब यहां पे
ये अलग-अलग यूजर नेम पासवर्ड का जो
कॉमिनेशन है वो ट्राई करेगा एंड यहां पे
आप देख सकते हैं टोटल जो रिक्वेस्ट काउंट
जाने वाली है 170000 के आसपास यहां पे
आपकी यह जाएगी एंड यह ट्राई करेगा उस
कॉमिनेशन को ब्रूट फोर्स करना शुरू कर
देगा एंड ये बेसिकली आपकी ब्रूट फोर्स चल
रही है ठीक है यह सारी ब्रूट फोर्सिंग हो
रही है अब इसमें दिक्कत एक चीज जरूर आ
सकती है अ वेफ की वेब एप्लीकेशन फायरवॉल
की सिक्योरिटी की वो आ सकती है उस परे भी
हम बाद में बात करेंगे फिलहाल मैं आपको
थोड़ा सा एक ओवरव्यू दे रहा हूं कि अगर
आपके पास एक कोई लॉगइन पेज मिल जाता है
पोर्ट्स के थ्रू या आईपी के थ्रू तो आप
क्या कर सकते हो राइट तो फिलहाल ये ब्रूट
फोर्स हो रहा है ब्रूट फोर्स को इसको आप
लेंथ और स्टेटस के अकॉर्डिंग फिल्टर कर
सकते हैं जैसे ये स्टेटस अभी 401 आ रहा है
सब कुछ यहां पे सारा 401 आ रहा है यहां पे
एंड लेंथ में आप देख सकते हैं लेंथ जो
जीरो लेंथ है उसकी 8456 है इससे बड़ी लेंथ
होनी चाहिए जो कि फिलहाल अभी हमारे पास
नहीं है तो इसको हमें चलने देना पड़ेगा
यहां पे थोड़ा सा टाइम लगता है ओबवियसली
अब बाकी आप आप इसको चलने दीजिए कुछ अगर
बढ़िया रिजल्ट्स आपको आ जाते हैं मे बी तो
आपको यहां पे स्टेटस 200 फाइंड करने हैं
मोस्टली 301 पे भी आप ट्राई आउट कर सकते
हैं जो रीडायरेक्ट कर देगा कहीं पे बट
स्टिल यू शुड बी गेटिंग दैट या 302 पे
राइट
ओके सो गॉट
इट यह समझ में आ रहा होगा आप लोगों को
यहां पे अभी फिलहाल हमें कोई 200 स्टेटस
नहीं मिला है इट मींस नथिंग नॉट एनी ऑफ द
यूजर नेम और पासवर्ड मैच इज मैचिंग तो
यहां पे थोड़ा रेट ट का भी इशू आएगा उसपे
हम बाद में जब रेट लिमिट वाली जब हम क्लास
करेंगे तो हम थोड़ा रेट लिमिट के बारे में
समझेंगे कि किस तरीके से ये काम करता है
कैसे बाईपास का हम ट्राई कर सकते हैं रेट
लिमिट के लिए राइट तो इस तरीके से आप रूट
फोर्स कर पाते हैं अगर आप करना है बब शूट
से यू कैन ट्राई दिस मेथड राइट
चलिए ओके मैं यहां पे क्लोज कर देता हूं
नाउ अब हम एक्चुअल जो हमारा आज का मोटो है
उस पर आ जाते हैं पहले मैं यहां पे सडन
में आप बहुत सारी चीजें ट्राई आउट कर सकते
हो यू कैन अभी एटीडी प स्टेटस 200 दिया
हमने डायरेक्टली आप ए ए सर्च कर सकते उस
पर्टिकुलर एसन के लिए जो भी रिजल्ट्स है
आपको मिल जाएंगे यहां प ज्यादा रिजल्ट हम
मिलेंगे तो ज्यादा अभी मैं यहां पे
सेटिंग्स प चल देता हूं एंड यहां पे
नेटवर्क प चलता हैं यहां पर सेटिंग्स प आ
जाते हैं लेट्स नो प्रॉक्सी एंड ओके एंड
नाउ अगेन वी कैन जस्ट रीलोड इट राइट तो
हमें अब ज्यादा रिजल्ट्स मिलेंगे साथ ही
नहीं मिलेंगे 138 मिल रहे हैं और ये सारी
आईपी जो है आपको यहां पे मिल रही है जो
आईपी यहां पे आपको मेंशन है यहां पे
अलग-अलग तरह की आईपी यहां पे आप देख सकते
हैं एंड यू कैन जस्ट नेविगेट थू दज आईपीस
टू सी इफ समथिंग इज देयर कुछ वहां पे कुछ
इंटरेस्टिंग कुछ चीज है यहां पे अवेलेबल
है कुछ चल रही है तो आप देख सकते हैं जैसे
आप देखिए यहां
पे एंड दिस इज सिक्योर कनेक्शन फेल्ड
व्हाई अ पीआर कनेक्ट रिसेट ओके ठीक है इज
एवरीथिंग गोइंग फाइन और कैन वी एबल टू
एक्सेस ऑल द वेबसाइट्स या वी कैन तो एक तो
ये तरीका आपका सिंपल सा तरीका अब हम आते
हैं एक्चुअल वे पे जो हम करने वाले हैं
बेसिकली समझने वाले हैं चलिए अब यहां पे
हमने टारगेट चूज किया
की मर्जी है हमने सोचा apple365.bet
[संगीत]
एसए नंबर मिल रहे हैं हम दोनों एक एल की
एक और एसएन नंबर आपको यहां पर भी देखने को
मिल रही है और भी एसए जो है ना एल के और
भी ऑर्गेनाइजेशंस जो है उनकी आपको यहां पे
बहुत सारी एस नंबर्स दिख रही है फिलहाल
ठीक है फिलहाल ये इंडिया वाली एल
ब्रॉडबैंड सर्विसेस है तो इस पे आपको नहीं
जाना है बेसिकली जो हमारा मेन हमारा एल
आसी है ये वाला इसको
हम एक्सप्लोर करने वाले हैं अब देखो जब एस
नंबर पता है तो तुम एस नंबर से क्या निकाल
सकते हो नेटवर्क रेंज या सीआईडीआर के
ब्लॉक्स फाइंड कर सकते हो क्या सीआइडिया
रेंजेस हैं इस पर्टिकुलर एसए नंबर के आप
यह फाइंड कर सकते हो यह चीज हमें फाइंड
करना है तो आप कैसे फाइंड करेंगे तो देयर
आर मल्टीपल वेज यू कैन फाइंड आउट दिस थिंग
ठीक है तो मैं क्या करता हूं मेरे अ सर्वर
को मैं एक बार रीलोड कर रीस्टार्ट कर लेता
हूं जो कि मैं डिजिटल ओसन पे चला रहा हूं
इसी पे यूज़ कर रहा हूं काफी इजी टू यूज़
होता है एंड काफी अच्छी खासी यहां पे आपको
फ्री क्रेडिट मिल जाती है 60 दिनों की 2
महीने की तो आपको इसी वीडियो के
डिस्क्रिप्शन में लिंक मिल जाएगा वहां से
जाके आप इस पे साइन अप कीजिएगा आपको दो
महीने के लिए $200 मिलेंगे और आपको दिख
रहा होगा यहां पे 15 दिन हो चुके हैं अभी
थोड़ा भी क्रेडिट यूज नहीं हुआ एक तरह से
तो कितना सफिशिएंट है आपके लिए आप आराम से
इसको यूटिलाइज कर सकते हैं ठीक है उसके
बाद भी जब आप पेड करेंगे भी तो आपको छ से
$8 पर मंथ का ही लगेगा बहुत ही कम होता है
एंड उसमें आपका सारा काम हो जाएगा ठीक है
चलिए अब यहां पे हमारा मशीन जो है मैं
इसको कनेक्ट कर लेता हूं अगेन मैं कनेक्ट
करने के लिए जो सॉफ्टवेयर यूज करता हूं वो
है मोबा एक्सटम तो मैं इसको स्टार्ट कर
लेता
हूं एंड लेट्स कनेक्ट इट मोबा एक्स्ट्रा
में जब आप एसएसए कर रहे होते हैं तो कुछ
देर जब रुक जाते हैं तो एसएसए कनेक्शन
आपका बंद हो जाता है याद रखिएगा वो
ऑटोमेटिक क्लोज होता है तो उससे अगर बचना
है आपको तो सिंपली आप सेटिंग्स में जाइएगा
कॉन्फिन वाले में एसएसए पे जाइएगा एंड
यहां पे आपको एक ऑप्शन मिलेगा एसएसए कीप
अलाइव इसको टिक कर दीजिएगा ओके कर दीजिएगा
एंड उसके बाद मोबाइल एक्सटम को बंद करके
वापस से क्लोज की स्टार्ट कीजिएगा देन यह
सेटिंग अप्लाइड होगी फिर आपका एसएसए
कनेक्शन लूज नहीं होगा आप जब तक कनेक्ट
करके रखना चाहे करके रख सकते हैं तो मैं
यहां पर कनेक्ट करने की कोशिश करता हूं
एंड यहां पर मैं अपना पासवर्ड एंटर कर
देता हूं एंड इट शुड बी कनेक्टेड शुड बी
कनेक्टेड राइट तो हमारा कनेक्ट हो चुका है
ओके सो ऑल गुड यहां पे अब यहां पे मेलस
ठीक है
डन चलिए अब एल की हमें आईपी ब्लॉक्स को
फाइंड पहले करनी है सी आईडिया रेंज फाइंड
करनी है उसके लिए हम क्या यूज कर सकते हैं
हम यहां पर हमने एक तो यह वाली सर्विस यूज
की बीजीपी ठीक है ये बीजीपी हमने सर्विस
यूज किया
दैट्ची
यह
एक ग्राफिकल टूल है बेसिकली इस पर आ जाते
हैं एंड यहां पर सुपर टूल का ऑप्शन मिलेगा
आप इस पर
जाइए यहां पर आने के बाद यहां पर एसन नंबर
डालिए तो एस नंबर सिर्फ 714 आप डाल सकते
हैं एस को हटा भी सकते हैं एंड यहां पर कर
दीजिए एन लुक अप वेर इ एस लुक अप एस लुकअप
और एंटर करिए और लेटस सी व्ट इ
हैपनिंग
दैट्ची है बट टोटल अमाउंट ऑफ आईपी एड्रेसस
आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे कितने आईपी
एड्रेस
हैं 36 लाख आईपी एड्रेसस यू आर गेटिंग
हियर एल का समझ में आ रहा है आपको 36 लाख
अब यहां पे ये
देखिए ठीक है ये तो आपका ये वाला एए हो
गया अब मैं यहां पे एक दूसरे वाली एए की
बात करता हूं यहां पे 6185
ठीक है 6185 और एंटर करते
हैं यहां
पे 27000 ऑफ आईपी एड्रेसस है इस वाले
पर्टिकुलर एसए के लिए ठीक है ओके य एसन
नंबर के लिए
हमारा एक और एसन नंबर है 6185 हमने ये
ट्राई कर लिया अब हम यहां पर एक एल आईसी
कर लेते हैं एंड दिस वन इज
2709 तो 2709 को ट्राई कर लेते हैं लेट्स
ट्राई टू फाइंड कितने आईपी एड्रेसस है
अ ऑलमोस्ट वही है सेम है सेम है ठीक है तो
ऑलमोस्ट उतना 27000 राइट तो अब हम कोई से
भी ऐसे नंबर को यहां पे एक चूज कर सकते
हैं उसके लिए फिर हम आगे अपना प्रोसेस कर
सकते हैं अब यह तो हमने क्या देखा हमने
देखा यहां पे एक m एक टूल बॉक्स एक
ग्राफिकल टूल का उसी तरीके से एक और
ग्राफिकल टूल है ए ए लक अप आप इसका भी यूज
कर सकते हैं एस एन लक अप यह एक वेबसाइट है
जस्ट गो
देर ठीक है ठीक है 3 करोड़ हो या 30 लाख
हो देख लो आप आप काउंट कर लो कोई दिक्कत
नहीं है ठीक है यहां पर हम आ चुके यहां पे
अब हम यहां एस नंबर से कर सकते हैं ए 714
यह वाली से हम लुक अप कर लेते एक बार 714
ही था ना आई थिंक यस से तो यहां देख सकते
हैं एल इंजीनियरिंग एल इंजीनियरिंग एंड
यहां पर आप देख सकते हैं इनकी सी आईडिया
रेंजेस देख रहे इतने सारे सीआईडीआर रेंजेस
आईपीवी वर्जन 6 के सीआईडीआर रेंजेस आपको
यहां पे दिख रहे हैं ठीक है तो ये
सीआईडीआर रेंजेस आपको यहां पे मिल गई ठीक
है बहुत सारे हैं लगभग 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 एंड यहां पे ये हो गए 20 और ये हो गया
30 ये हो ग 40 38 ऑलमोस्ट 38 यहां पे आपको
सीआईडी रेंजेस मिल जा रहे हैं इस वाले से
ठीक है अब यहां पे हम एक टूल का भी यूज कर
सकते हैं एंड दैट टूल इज फ्रॉम प्रोजेक्ट
डिस्कवरी एसए मैप
वी कैन यूज दिस टूल आल्सो एस मैप ठीक है
तो एन मैप में आप सिंपली क्या करना चाहते
हो कैसे आप इंस्टॉल करना है गो से गो में
रिटन टूल है सिंपली इसको कॉपी कीजिए और
अपने सर्वर पे एग्जीक्यूट कर दीजिए सिंपल
एज सिंपल एज दैट यहां से कॉपी कीजिए
इंस्टॉल करने के लिए यहां पे पेस्ट कर
दीजिए एंड यहां पे एंटर कर दीजिए एंड इट
विल गेट इंस्टॉल्ड सो आई हैव ऑलरेडी
इंस्टॉल्ड आई एम नॉट गोइंग टू इंस्टॉल इट
नाउ हियर अब आपको ए
मैप हान h करना है आपको इसकी हेल्प फाइल
मिल जाएगी और आपको यहां पर दिख रहा होगा
कैसे यूज करना है टारगेट एसए टू लुक अप
ठीक है तो हान ए आपको टैग देना है तो चलिए
मैं यहां पे एस ए मैप दे देता हूं हान ए
एंड हमारा टारगेट ए ए है ए
714 ठीक है
[संगीत]
दैट्ची हाई फनल लेट्स सी यह टोटल जो ब्लॉक
ओके एसन ब्लॉकेज है यहां पे
एसन के 714 के 1314 है 1314 य आर गेटिंग
गाइ ये बहुत बड़ी नंबर है सी आईडीएल ब्लॉक
की बहुत यूज बहुत यूज आप देख सकते हैं य
बहुत बड़ी है अब मैं यहां पे अगर मैं यहां
पे आपको
दिखाऊं इस वाले टारगेट इस वाले वेबसाइट प
चलके कि यहां मैं लुकअप प चलता हूं मैं
यहां प apple.com को पहले एक बार पिंग
करता हूं ठीक है मैं क्या करता हूं पि
apple.com लेट्स गेट द आईपी एड्रेस हियर
वी आर नॉट गेटिंग आईपी वर्जन फो तो यहां
पे वर्जन फोर के लिए न 4 लगा देते हैं एंड
यहां पे हम एक आईपी मिल गई तो हम इस आईपी
के लिए पर्टिकुलर सर्च करके देख सकते हैं
तो हमने आईपी यहां से कॉपी किया यहां
पेस्ट किया एंड यहां पे अब लुक अप कर लेते
हैं अब लुक अप करेंगे तो यहां पे आपको देख
सकते हैं 714 वाली ही एसएन नंबर जो है
हमारी आई है यही हमारा जो मेन एसए है इसकी
ये तो लाइक पूरी आईपी रेंज भी नहीं दी गई
है यहां पे बट यहां पे आपको ये सारी आईपी
प्रॉपर आईपी रेंज यहां पे मिल चुकी है जो
कितने हैं 1314 1314 समझ में आ रहा है अब
अब
एसन
मैप यहां पर एक फीचर है लेट मी शो
यू इ देर एनी काउंट फीचर आई थिंक काउंट
फीचर इसमें नहीं होगा चलिए हमने तो काउंट
वैसे कर लिया है बट ठीक है तो हमें यहां
पर सिंपली अगर देखे 714 की तो यहां पर
1314 सी आईडिया रेंजेस आपको मिल रही है यह
बहुत ह्यूज लिस्ट होती है चलिए तो अब मैं
क्या करूंगा यहां पे एमकेडी आई आर एंड
यहां पे मैं एक एल नाम का एक
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री अब हमें एक फाइल बन गई
है एल सटी अब इसको तुम कैट करोगे एल सीआ
तो आपको सारी सीआईडीआर जो है जो भी हमने
फाइंड किए व यहां पर मिल जाएंगी एंड यहां
पर हम इसको काउंट भी करें तो सेम नंबर
आपको 1314 के आसपास समझ मिल जाएगा ठीक
है क्या बोल रहे
हो पोर्ट फगर की लैब लैब्स करो सॉल्व
लैब्स नहीं करेंगे सॉल्व अभी लैब्स अभी हम
रियल टारगेट प ही करेंगे सारा जैसे जैसे
मैं करता जाऊं वैसे-वैसे आप कीजिए लैप्स
अगर आपको सॉल्व करना है आप सेम टॉपिक के
लिए लैप्स को सॉल्व कर सकते हैं अपने से
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है ठीक है स्पून फीडिंग
वाला काम नहीं है कि मुंह में चम्मच से
खिला दो आपको खुद से भी एक्सप्लोर करना है
राइट एंड यहां पे जब हम रियल टारगेट प
करते हैं तो हम रियल थोड़ा सा फील आउट
करते हैं ट्स वई रियल टार्गेट ठीक है
लैप्स के लिए बाद में टाइम आएगा हमारा
उसके टेंशन नहीं लेनी है जब लैप्स कराऊंगा
तो आप लोग बोलोगे रियल टारगेट प आ जाओ तो
थोड़ा अंदर से सुकून रखो यार ठीक है ओके
तो यह हमारे पास जनरेट होके आ चुकी है
यहां पे सीआई एल की मिल चुकी है अब इतना
आपको शायद समझ में आ गया होगा इसको हम एक
और तरीके से किस तरीके से कर सकते हैं
यहां पे हम इस तरीके से भी ए मैप को यूज
कर सकते हैं लाइक इ कर सकते हैं यहां पे इ
एंड उसके बाद हम टारगेट की जो भी हम एस
नंबर प्रोवाइड करना है हम एस नंबर
प्रोवाइड कर सकते हैं एस 714 एस 714 हमने
प्रोवाइड किया एंड उस हम गप सॉरी पाइप यूज
करके यहां हम ए ए मैप यूज कर सकते हैं और
फिर एंटर करेंगे तो आपको वही सेम रिजल्ट्स
मिल जाएगी और डब्लू सफन एल से आपको मैं
दिखा देता हूं 1314 ही आपको रिजल्ट मिलेगा
तो इको वाला भी आप सिस्टम यूज कर सकते हैं
ये आपके इसके हेल्प फाइल में भी आपको दिख
जाएगी इस टूल के जब आप इस टूल को नीचे
एक्सप्लोर करेंगे यू कैन सी हाउ टू यूज
दिस टूल्स ठीक है तो आप एसए नंबर के थ्रू
कर सकते हैं डोमेन नेम के थ्रू कर सकते
हैं आईपी के थ्रू कर सकते हैं एंड
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन नेम के थ्रू भी कर सकते हैं
ठीक है तो हमें यहां पे सी आईडिया रेंज
मिल चुकी है अब सी आईडिया रेंज मिल चुकी
है तो हम में अब आईपी एड्रेसस चाहिए
एसोसिएटेड विद दैट पर्टिकुलर सीआई सीआईडी
रेंज तो अब आईपी एड्रेसस निकालने का बहुत
सिंपल तरीका है ग्राफिकली तो आपको पता ही
है कैसे आईपी सी आईडिया टू आईपी है ना सी
आईडिया टू आईपी ये
वाला
अ ये वाला यूज कर लीजिए कोई सा भी सर्विस
यूज कर लीजिए बहुत सारे सर्विसेस आते हैं
यहां पे एंड यहां पे आप सीआईडीआर रेंजेस
डालेंगे एंड आईपी एड्रेसस जो आ जाएंगी
बहुत सारी और भी आईपी एड्रेस गाइड की भी
आती है बट यहां पे पे हम जो यूज करने वाले
हैं दूसरा टूल वो है आपका मैप
सीआईडीआर वी आर गोइंग टू यूज द टूल मैप
सीआईडीआर अगेन बाय प्रोजेक्ट डिस्कवरी एंड
इसको इंस्टॉल करने के लिए सिंपली क्या
करना है अ सिंपल यही गो इंस्टॉल वाली
कमांड है बस सिंपल पेस्ट कीजिए एंटर कीजिए
दैट्ची है अब यहां पे आपको दिखा दिखाता
हूं मैं कि इसमें कितनी आईपी एड्रेसस हैं
किस तरीके से
अब यहां पे
सीआईडीआर आपको कैसे यूज करना है मैप
सीआईडीआर कमांड हान सीआईडीआर और सीआईडीआर
जिस फाइल में है उसके लिस्ट उसका नाम आपको
दे देना है तो सिंपल सा पहले मैं कर देता
हूं मैप सीआईडीआर यह कमांड
चलाया ठीक है मैप सी आईडिया कर दिया हमने
हान सीआईडीआर आर्गुमेंट लगा दिया और उसके
बाद एल टारगेट जो है सीआईडीआर का वो दे
दिया और यहां पे हम एंटर कर देंगे अब हम
एंटर करेंगे तो हमने जो टारगेट लिस्ट दी
थी उसके अंदर की ये पूरी आईपी एड्रेसस
आपको प्रोवाइड कर रहा है जितनी आईपी
एड्रेसस उसके अंदर आ सकती थी वो सारी आपके
अंदर आपको यहां पे मिलेगी ऑलमोस्ट 30 लाख
के आसपास मलब बहुत बड़ी रेंज है तो वो
करते आप रहोगे यह चलता जाएगा तो कोई फायदा
नहीं है यह पर्टिकुलर आपके रैम को
यूटिलाइज किया जा रहा है यहां पे तो थोड़ा
इसको मैं स्लो कर देता हूं एंड यहां पे
मैं इसको बंद कर देता हूं ठीक है अब मैं
यहां पे वर्ड काउंट अगर मैं आपको दिखाऊं
तो यहां पे थोड़ी देर आपको वेट करना ही
पड़ेगा क्योंकि बहुत ह्यूज लिस्ट है तभी
आपको वर्ड काउंट मिलके भी आएगी अ एंड आपको
ऑलमोस्ट वही जो रेंज आपको एए टूल बॉक्स पे
दिखा था 30 लाख या 3 करोड़ जो भी था वो
आपको यहां पे दिख जाएगा तो यह पूरी आईपी
एड्रेसस
की गो एप गो एप कौन सा है भाई गो ऐप तो
नहीं है कोई सभी गो तो आपका टूल है गो
लैंग्वेज है मतलब इंस्टॉल करते हो आप गो
के गो से बनी सॉफ प्रोग्राम्स
को रन करने के लिए ठीक है
तो ये आपको इस तरीके से आपको यहां पे
डब्ल्यू स आईल कर लीजिएगा डब्ल्यू स हा
फनल आपको लिस्ट पूरी मिल जाएगी कितनी सारी
आईपी ड्रेसेस हैं चलो ये तो हमने देख लिया
अब यहां पे मैप सीआईडीआर हान h
करेंगे तो आप एक पर्टिकुलर सिंपल एक
पर्टिकुलर
एक सिंगल आईपी या सीआईडीआर को भी आप यहां
पे यूटिलाइज कर सकते हो ये समझ लीजिए ठीक
है मैप सीआईडीआर के अंदर में आप इसको आप
उसके अंदर की आईपी रेंजेस फाइंड कर सकते
हो जैसे हमारे पास बहुत सारी बड़ी बहुत
बड़ी आई है ना सीआई रेंज जसे मै कैट करता
हूं एंड यहां पे मैं एल सीआईडीआर को करता
हूं यहां पे मैं एंटर करता हूं तो हमारे
पास ये सारी सीआईडीआर रेंज आई है ठीक है
चलिए मैं यहां पे दिखा देता हूं यहां पे
बहुत बड़ी सी आईडिया रेंज
है ये पूरी सीआईडी रेंज हो गई अब मान लो
मुझे मेरे को एक सीआईडी रेंज ये वाला
चाहिए मैं इसको कॉपी कर लेता हूं एंड मैं
देखता हूं इसके अंदर कितनी सारी आईपीस हैं
तो इसके लिए मैं क्या यूज करूंगा मैं
सिंपल एक कमांड डालूंगा व्हाट कमांड आई
विल यूज मैप सीआईडीआर न सीआईडीआर एंड यहां
पे मैं रेंज दे दूंगा जो हमारा सीआईडीआर
रेंज है एंड
दैट्ची न l यहां पे
16384 ये आप न सी लगा के भी एक सीट
आर्गुमेंट है इसमें तब भी आप देख सकते हैं
16384 आईपी एड्रेसस हैं एक पर्टिकुलर सी
आईडिया रेंज में भाई इसमें ओनली इसमें
सोचो बाकी में
कितने गट इट इतना समझ में आ गया इतना तो
क्लियर होगा मेरे ख्याल से आप इसको वैसे
भी कर सकते हैं जो कमांड आपने यह दिया ना
आप इसको ऐसे भी कर सकते हैं
देखो
इको ठीक है इको और यह आईपी रेंज यहां पर
हमने दे दिया य अब हम यहां पर मैप
सीआईडीआर सॉरी सॉरी
सॉरी मैप सीआईडीआर लगा देते एंड यहां पर
हाइन साइलेंट कर देते हैं साइलेंट ऑप्शन
बस आईपी शो करेगा आपको ओनली एंड यहां पर
अगर डब्लू सफन एल करोगे तो वही 16000 कम
से कम कुछ इस तरीके से आप कमांड को यूज कर
सकते हो ऐसे भी यूज कर सकते हो यहां पर
सिंपल पाइप का मतलब यही होता है कि इको
मतलब यह वाली जो पर्टिकुलर इनपुट है यह
इसके आउटपुट को इसको इनपुट दे दो और इसके
आउटपुट को इसमें इनपुट दे दो इस तरीके से
कंकूट वली काम करता है आपका जो पाइप है
ठीक है चलो तो अब ये तो हमें मिल गया मैं
यहां पे क्लियर कर लेता हूं अब यहां पे
हमने यह वाला चीज तो कर दिया अब यहां पे
मैं एक बार इसकी आउटपुट फाइल भी ले लेता
हूं आउटपुट फाइल के लिए हम क्या कर सकते
हैं हान o लगा सकते हैं बिल्कुल परफेक्ट
सो नाउ लेट्स ट्राई टू डू लेट्स ट्राई टू
गेट इट इन अवर फाइल तो हम यहां पे न o दे
देते हैं एंड यहां पे एल अ
आईपीस . txt.gz
फाइल सॉरी नेम एल आईपी एल आ हो गई तो अब
मैं देख लेता हूं इसके अंदर कितने एल आईपी
के अंदर कितने सारी एंट्रीज है डब्
सीनल 16384 तो हम हमारे पास सारी आईपी जो
है ना एल की वो आ चुकी है यह देखिए य रेंज
की जो आईपी है अब यह जो आईपी आपके पास आ
चुकी है मैं अब आपको एक चीज दिखाता हूं
मोबा एक्सम यूज करोगे तो थोड़ा इजी हो
जाता है जैसे अब मैं क्या करता हूं एसएसए
वाले उस पर मैं एक बार चलता हूं यहां पर
रिकनेक्ट करता हूं
यह लेफ्ट साइड में एसएसए ब्राउजर होता है
जिसमें आप फाइल्स को ब्राउज कर सकते हैं
अपने सर्वर पर जो भी फाइल्स है मैं री
कनेक्ट करता हूं क्या हो रहा है भाई री
कनेक्ट नहीं हो
रहाय ओ लेट्स वेट थोड़ा वेट कर लेते
[संगीत]
हैं ओके यर एलस एसएसए ब्राउजर रिकनेक्ट
नहीं हो पा रहा
है
जस्ट ट्राई टू री
कनेक्ट ओके लेट्स री कनेक्ट अगेन कोई बात
नहीं लेट्स
रीस्टार्ट ओके इट शुड बी नाउ
कनेक्टिंग
ओके
ये रहा हां अब कनेक्ट हो गया अब यहां पे
मेरे पास एक आईपी रेंज आईपी की लिस्ट आ
चुकी है राइट तो हम इस आईपी को ओपन कर
लेते हैं यहां पे मैं
हैकर हैकर फील आती है क्या बात
है ठीक है अब यहां प आ चुकी है य प एंड यू
कैन सी हियर जस्ट वेट वेर इट इ द वेर इ द
फाइल कहां गई भैया फाइल अच्छा फाइल अभी आई
नहीं क्या ओके यह डाउनलोड हो रहा है
डाउनलोडिंग एलपी 0 पर क्यों भाई बहुत बड़ी
फाइल है
क्या ज्यादा तो है नहीं चीज 16000 समथिंग
ही है टेक्स्ट फाइल है वो
तो कम ऑन हरी अप हरी अप हरी अप जल्दी हो
जाओ भाई जल्दी यहां पर लेफ्ट साइड में
नीचे में यहां पर डाउनलोड हो रहा है देख
लो मैं यहां
पे कैंसिल
अगेन लेट्स ट्राई टू डाउनलोड
इट कितनी बड़ी फाइल है यार छोटी सी फाइल
है फ दिक्कत क्यों आ रही है
इनी बहुत छोटी सी फाइल है देन वई इट नॉट
गेटिंग डाउनलोडेड लेट्स डाउनलोड इट अगेन
डेस्कटॉप प ही रखते हैं ओके फिर से ट्राई
कर लेते हैं एक बार कुछ इश्यूज
होंगे हो हो हो हो हो
हो ओके लेट्स कॉपी इट
लेट्स लेट्स ट्राई टू ओपन
इट गाइस प्लीज आप लोग इधर ध्यान
दीजिए सर की चैनल को देखा कुछ लोगों ने नू
चैनल बनाया ओके
ओके प्लीज इधर ध्यान दीजिए आप लोग गाइस
प्लीज ठीक है र ट्राइट गेट दिस ऑन आवर
होस्ट
मशीन इफ वी कैन गेट लेट
सी ओके लेट्स क्लोज इट ओके कुछ इशू आ रही
है बट अभी थोड़ी देर में सही हो जाएंगी
शायद इसको डाउनलोड ये डाउनलोड हो गया
क्या
ओके लेट्स रिबूट द मशीन वंस एक बार रिबूट
कर लेते
हैं
सॉरी लेट्स लेट्स एक्सक्यूट इट कनेक्ट एस
रूट रिबूट हो जाने देते एक
बार
अभी रिबूट हुआ नहीं
है लेट
रिबूट डेस्कटॉप में आ गई है कहां यार एल
वाली
फाइल नहीं आई है
भाई आई होती तो मैंने देख लिया होता ना
नहीं आई है चलो रिबूट हो गया है हमारा
मशीन तो अब कनेक्ट हो जाएगा कोई प्रॉब्लम
नहीं है लेट्स एक्यूट इट सो लेट्स गिव द
पासवर्ड एंड
दैट्ची की है एंड यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं
कि सारी आईपी एड्रेसस एसोसिएटेड विद
हमारे पास आईपी की पूरी रेंज आ चुकी है हम
अब पोर्ट स्कैनिंग कर सकते हैं इन आईपीस
पे ह्यूज लिस्ट है वी कैन डू द पोर्ट
स्कैनिंग पार्ट अब इसको अलग-अलग तरीके
ग्राफिकल वे में विंडोज से आपको करना है
देयर इज अ वेरी पॉपुलर टूल कौन सा टूल है
बताओ देयर इज अ वेरी वेरी पॉपुलर टूल दैट
इज एंग्री आईपी स्कैनर एंड आप इसको यूज कर
सकते हैं लेट्स ओपन एंग्री आईपी स्कैनर
यहां पे आप आएंगे तो यहां पे बेसिकली बाय
डिफॉल्ट आपका आईपी रेंज होता है जो आप
आईपी रेंज यूज कर सकते हैं आप इसको ड्रॉप
डाउन से टेक्स्ट फाइल चूज कर सकते हैं
यहां पे आके ब्राउज कर सकते हैं और वो जो
फाइल है apple.us को ओपन कर सकते हैं एंड
उसके बाद यहां पे स्टार्ट कर सकते हैं नाउ
इट विल स्टार्ट स्कैनिंग ऑल द आईपीस एंड
टू फाइंड पॉसिबल ओपन आईपी एड्रेसस जो ओपन
है अ पोर्ट वैसे आईपी एड्रेसस जिस पे
पोर्ट्स कोई ओपन है ठीक है व आपको फाइंड
करके देगा डिफॉल्ट जो है आपके 8443 पोर्ट
ही जनरली यह देता है बट और भी पोर्ट्स अगर
मिलेंगे आपको तो ये प्रोवाइड करेगा एंड
आपको यहां पे दिख रहा होगा यहां पे गो टू
कंट्रोल ज से नेक्स्ट ओपन पोर्ट के लिए तो
कंट्रोल प्रेस करते हैं कोई ओपन पोर्ट है
क्या
अभी अभी तक तो कुछ नहीं है कोई ओपन पोर्ट
अभी तक हमें मिला नहीं है स्क्रॉल करेंगे
यहां पे तो ये पोर्ट्स जो मिल रहे हैं
यहां पे बेसिकली ये अलाइव होस्ट है यह जो
अलाइव होस्ट है कंट्रोल एच से तो आप अलाइव
होस्ट पे जाएंगे यहां पे ये ये सारे अलाइव
होस्ट है तो आप कॉपी करके यहां पर एक बार
चेक आउट कर सकते हैं व्हाट्स देयर ऑन दिस
पर्टिकुलर आईपी कुछ है क्या इस आईपी
एड्रेस
पे लेट्स सी
नथिंग एंग्री बर्ड नहीं भाई एंग्री आईपी
स्कैनर एंग्री बर्ड ठीक है तो यहां पे
हमें ग्रीन अगर ग्रीन में कुछ मिल रहा है
वो ओपन पोर्ट के साथ व आईपी होता है अगर
ग्रीन में मिल रहा है आपको तो रेड वाले को
तो टच ही मत करो और ब्लू वाले हैं जो
अलाइव होस्ट है ठीक है तो अगर कुछ ग्रीन
मिलता है तो वी कैन सी दैट सो वी विल लेट
इट स्कैन हम इसको स्कैन होने
देंगे एंड जस्ट मिनिमाइज इट राइट तो ये
स्कैन हो रहा है इसको चलने देते हैं अब
यहां पे ये तो हमने कर दिया किसका यूज
करके एंग्री आईपी स्क स्कैनर का हमने यूज
किया अब हम यहां पे
दूसरे मैं इसको क्लोज कर देता हूं अब यहां
पे अब दूसरे टूल्स का भी यूटिलाइजेशन कर
सकते हैं दूसरे टूल्स भी हम यूज कर सकते
हैं तो अब यहां पे प्रोजेक्ट डिस्कवरी की
जब हमने
सीआईडीआर मैपिंग वाली यूज की मैप सीआईडीआर
तो हमने मैप सीआईडीआर से हमें सारी आईपी
एड्रेसस जो है वो निकल के मिल चुकी है अब
इसके बाद जो है हम मैप सीआईडीआर के साथ डी
डीएनएस एक्स को यूज करके डोमेन नेम निकाल
सकते हैं वी कैन फाइंड सम डोमेन
नेम्स बहुत ही इंटरेस्टिंग चीज है कैसे
भैया तो मैं अभी आपको दिखाता हूं ना हमें
कौन सी सीआईडीआर की आईपी रेंज मिली हुई थी
हमने कौन सा सीआईडीआर यूज किया था सीडी
एपल कैट एल सीआईडीआर और हमने सबसे पहला
वाला जो सीआईडीआर था आई थिंक उसी का यूज
किया था
राइट उसी स्कैन किया था
ना चलो कोई बात नहीं यहां पर ऊपर चले ते
ऊपर चलते हैं लेट्स फाइंड आउट यह वाली
हमने यूज की थी यह वाला सीआईडीआर हमने यूज
किया
था दिस वन लेट्स कॉपी इट सम वेयर ठीक है
जो सीआईडीआर हम यूज कर रहे हैं हमने यह
वाला यूज किया था ठीक है ओके चलिए
अब नाउ व्हाट वी विल डू व्हाट वी विल डू
हम यहां पे डीएनए x का यूज करेंगे किसके
साथ मैप सीआईडीआर के साथ कैसे यूज करेंगे
क्या करेंगे देखिए सिंपल हम क्या करेंगे इ
को कमांड एक लगाएंगे उसके बाद हम जो
सीआईडीआर हम यूज हमने किया था उस सीआईडीआर
को यहां पे मेंशन करेंगे जो भी हमारा
टारगेट सीआईडीआर उसको मेंशन करेंगे उसके
बाद हम यहां लगाएंगे मैप
सीआईडीआर ठीक है मैप सीआईडीआर लगा लिया
उसके बाद यहां हान साइलेंट लगा देते हैं
ओनली आउटपुट देगा जो हमारा आउटपुट होगा
वही आउटपुट देगा ये हमने कर दिया उसके बाद
हम यहां पे डीएनए x यूज करने वाले हैं
इसके लिए आपका डीएनए एक टूल इंस्टॉल्ड
होना चाहिए अब ये कैसे आप इंस्टॉल करेंगे
गाइज बहुत सिंपल सा तरीका है डीएनए एक
प्रोजेक्ट डिस्कवरी गिट पेज पे आ जाइएगा
एंड ये भी एक गो में रिटन टूल है बस इसको
यहां पे कॉपी मारने का और यहां पे आके
सिंपली यहां
पे पेस्ट कर दीजिएगा एंटर कीजिएगा आपका
डीएनएस एक्स जो है वो इंस्टॉल हो जाएगा
दैट्ची पर्पस डीएनएस टूल किट डिजाइंड फॉर
रनिंग डीएनएस क्वेरीज अलग-अलग डीएनएस
क्वेरीज के लिए यह यूज़ में लिया जाता है
जैसे अगर आपको एक लिस्ट ऑफ डोमेन या होस्ट
है जिसमें से आपको सी नेम रिकॉर्ड निकालना
है टी एक्सटी रिकॉर्ड निकालना है ए
रिकॉर्ड निकालना है पीटीआर रिकॉर्ड
निकालना है तो आप डीएनए एकस का यूज कर
सकते हैं ठीक है तो इसलिए हम डीएनए एकस का
यूज़ क्यों कर रहे हैं हमें जो आईपी
एड्रेसस आ रही है हमारे
पास उसके पॉसिबल होस्ट नेम्स फाइंड करने
और यह काम डीएनएस एक बहुत इजली करेगा
होस्ट नेम मतलब आईपी एड्रेस से कनेक्टेड
डोमेन जो होगा वह फाइंड करने अब चलिए कैसे
तो यहां पर हम इको
करेंगे हमारा जो रेंज है सॉरी हमारी जो सी
आईडिया रेंज है हम उसको मेंशन
करेंगे सो लेट्स कॉपी द सी आईडी रेंज
यर
मतलब सीआईडी रेंज को हमने इको कराया कहां
पर हम इसको कहां पर कराएंगे मैप सीआईडीआर
में यहां पर मैप सीआईडीआर हाइ फन साइलेंट
यूज कर रहा हूं मैं उसके बाद यहां पर
डीएनएस एक्स डीएनएस एक्स टूल का यूज
करेंगे और इसमें डीएनएस एक्स में हम एक
आर्गुमेंट देंगे हाइन पीटीआर पीटीआर क्या
होता है मैं आपको बता देता हूं देख लीजिए
यहां पर पीटीआर रिकॉर्ड्स अगर आप सर्च
करेंगे तो आपको यहां पे मिलेगा ये देखिए अ
डीएनएस पीटीआर रिकॉर्ड इज यूज्ड फॉर
रिवर्स डीएनएस लुकअप्स एंड इट मैचेस डोमेन
नेम्स विथ आईपी एड्रेस मतलब यहां पे क्या
होगा ना कि उल्टा होगा देखो यहां पे अ
पॉइंटर रिकॉर्ड रिजॉल्व एन आईपी एड्रेस
इनटू अ डोमेन नेम डीएनएस का काम क्या था
डोमेन को आईपी ये उल्टा यहां पे आपका कर
देगा रिवर्स डीएनएस आईपी को डोमेन में
पॉसिबल डोमस फाइंड करके आपको दे देगा इस
पर्टिकुलर आईपी रेंज के लिए तो डीएनए न
पीटीआर हमने दे दिया अब यहां पर एक
और टैब यूज करेंगे हाइन रेस्प ओनली मतलब
डीएनएस रिस्पांस जो आ रहा है हमें बस उसी
का यूज करना है ट्स इट बस इतना ही करना है
बस कहानी खत्म अब हमें यहां पर एंटर करना
है और देखना है कि हमें कुछ रिजल्ट मिलता
भी है कि नहीं मिलता है लेट्स सी ओ माय
गॉड व आर गेटिंग सम
डोमस
देखो
जस्ट वेट आपको कुछ यहां दिख रहा है आप
लोगों को दिख रहा है यहां पर हमें इस आईपी
रेंज में यह पर्टिकुलर डोमस मिल रहे हैं
यहां पर यह वह डोमस है जो यह फाइंड किया
है इसने पर्टिकुलर इस सी आईडिया रेंज के
लिए वी विल वेट सम मोर
टाइम
थोड़ा और वेट
करेंगे अच्छा जो भी चैट में इ रिलेटेड
बातें कर रहे हैं मैं उनको रिमूव कर दूंगा
एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी बट आई विल रिमूव देम ए
टाइम आउट देम
राइट सो प्लीज
डोंट इट्स अ
रिक्वेस्ट ओके सो ी गेटिंग सम मोर डोमस सम
इंटरेस्टिंग डोमेंस कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग डोमस
आपको यहां पर दिख रहे हैं यह देखिए
यू कैन व्यू द डोमेंस क्या है यह किस
तरीके से इसके ऊपर आप अलग-अलग तरह की
चीजें कर सकते हैं डायरेक्टरी बड फोर्सिंग
कर सकते हैं और भी चीजें कर सकते हैं व
विल बी वेटिंग फॉर सम मोर रिजल्ट्स
हियर
दिस इज लाइक आप आईपी एड्रेसस से डोमस वो
फाइंड कर रहे हैं जो आप सब डोमेंस में
नहीं फाइंड कर रहे हैं समझ में आ रहा है
जो आप सब डोमस में फाइंड नहीं कर रहे
बेसिकली तो यू आर गेटिंग अ लार्ज स्कोप
एरिया ठीक
है चलिए मैं यहां
पर
विल बी
वेटिंग ओके डन तो हमें यहां पे कुछ डोमस
यहां पे फाइंड होके मिले हैं यहां पे कुछ
इंटरेस्टिंग यहां पे डोमस और भी यहां पे
निकल के आए हैं एंड जब हमने ये चीज यहां
पे मैप किया हुआ है ठीक है हमने जैसे ही
हमने यहां पे ये आईपी रेंज जो हमने सीआईडी
रेंज दी तो हमें इससे रिलेटेड जो है डोमस
यहां पे मिल गई है अब मैप सीआईडीआर के
अंदर में यहां पे हमने तो एक सिंपल एक
सिंगल आईपी रेंज यहां पे दिया सीआईडीआर
रेंज दिया इसके अंदर हम मल्टीपल सीआईडीआर
रेंजेस भी दे सकते हैं वी कैन ट्राई टू
डिफाइन दैट हियर ठीक है तो मैप सीआईडीआर
के अंदर भी आप डायरेक्टली चला सकते हैं
इसको जैसे अगर आप देखेंगे मैप सीआईडीआर
हान
h तो यहां पे जब आप देखेंगे तो हियर हान स
डीआर देके आप सीआईडीआर की पूरी फाइल लिस्ट
आप दे सकते हैं एंड उसपे आप डीएनए एक भी
चला सकते हैं ठीक है मैप सीआईडीआर यहां पे
हान सीआईडीआर एंड यहां पे आप एल सटी कर
सकते हैं यहां पे आप पाइप देके एंड यहां
पे हम डीएनए एक को यूज कर सकते हैं अगेन
हान पीटीआर रिकॉर्ड हमें चाहिए हान पीटीआर
रिकॉर्ड के लिए हम जाते हैं हान रेस्प हान
ओनली कर देते हैं और एंटर करेंगे तो यू
वुड बी गेटिंग द कनेक्टेड होस्ट नेम्स जो
भी यह ट्राई करेगा फाइंड करने का आपको मिल
जाएगा वहां पे ठीक है सो लेट्स सी इफ यू
गेटिंग
समथिंग तो हमने क्या किया हमने इसके
आउटपुट को इसका आउटपुट क्या होगा
apple.tv पीटीआर रिकॉर्ड के लिए राइट बस
ट्स इट सेम काम जो हम पहले कर रहे
थे सो वी हैव टू वेट सम टाइम थोड़ा वेट
करना पड़ेगा आपको इसके लिए
राइट बहुत लोगों के दिमाग से ऊपर जा रहा
होगा बट बहुत काम की चीज है य याद रखिएगा
अभी मैं अभी आऊंगा और भी बहुत सारी चीज
अभी आनी बाकी है भाई अभी देखते जाओ देखते
जाओ देखते
जाओ ठीक
है
चलिए लेट्स वेट लेट्स
वेट थोड़ा टाइम लगेगा तब तक एंग्री आईपी
स्कैनर पे आ जाते हैं आप यहां पे देख सकते
हैं यहां पे स्कैन हो चुकी है यहां पे
टोटल अलाइव होस्ट 522 है बट यहां पे कोई
भी ओपन होस्ट आई थिंक नहीं मिले हैं इस
कोर्स राइट यस वी डन गेट एनी ओपन होस्ट
कोई ओपन होस्ट यहां पे नहीं मिली हमें तो
कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है कोई बात नहीं मैं
इसको कैंसिल कर देता हूं यहां पे एंड यस
ट्स इट तब तक यहां पे वेट करते हैं यहां
पे एंड यहां पे हमें रिजल्ट्स मिलेंगे
थोड़ा टाइम लगेगा कोई दिक्कत नहीं तब तक
हम दूसरे टूल पे भी आ जाते हैं तो यह आप
इस तरीके से क्या कर सकते हैं निकाल सकते
हैं लाइक मैं आपको थोड़ा गाइड कर ही देता
हूं हर चीज में तो आपको थोड़ा सा आईडिया
लग जाता है तो यहां से आपको क्या मिल गया
अ बेसिकली यहां पे सीआईडी रेंज तो मिल ही
गई
स आईआर की जगह पे तो आपको सेम रिजल्ट्स जो
है वो मिल जाएंगे ठीक है तो आपको ये जो
डोमेंस है जो हिडन डोमेंस है बेसिकली वो
डोमेंस आपको यहां पे मिल जाते हैं राइट
दैट्ची ठीक है नाबू नाबू क्या करता है
नाबू इज़ अ पोर्ट स्कैनिंग टूल रिटेन इन
गो दैट अलाउ यू टू इनमेट वैलिड पोर्ट्स
फॉर होस्ट इन अ फास्ट एंड रिलायबल मैनर इट
इज़ अ सिंपली रिटन टूल ऐसे ऐसे यह सब यूज़
करता है सीन कनेक्ट एंड यूडीपी स्कंस को
अह या होस्ट या लिस्ट ऑफ़ होस्ट के लिए
एंड लिस्ट ऑल पोर्ट्स दैट रिटर्न अ
रिप्लाई जो पोर्ट्स रिप्लाई करते हैं
रिटर्न उनको यह लिस्ट करता है सिंपल सी
चीज़ है इसको यूज़ करने का सिंपल तरीका
क्या है नाबू h hackerone.com जैसे यहां
दिया हुआ है वैसे आप अपने टारगेट के लिए
यूज कर सकते हो जैसे मेरे पास क्या है मैं
यहां पे नाबू इंस्टॉल कैसे करना है बहुत
सिंपल सा तरीका है जैसा मैंने बताया था
आपको ये भी गो में रिटन टूल ही
है ये रहा यहां से कॉपी यहां से पेस्ट एंड
एंटर एंड इंस्टॉल्ड अब यहां पे मैं नाबू
करूंगा हान एच दूंगा एंटर ठीक
है अब मैं यहां पे क्या करूंगा यहां पे
सिंपल एक होस्ट को स्कैन करने के लिए हान
होस्ट एंड
दैट्ची फम एंड एंटर जैसे मैं एंटर करूंगा
यहां पे रनिंग डिस्कवरी होस्ट डिस्कवरी
स्कैनिंग कर रहा है और यहां पे पता चला कि
पोर्ट 80n 443 दो पोर्ट्स के साथ ही आपको
रिजल्ट दे रहा है ठीक है अब मुझे अगर इस
पर्टिकुलर होस्ट के लिए लेट्स सपोज मुझे
और भी पोर्ट्स को स्कैन करने हैय बाय
डिफॉल्ट तो इसने 8443 यहां पे दे दिया अब
यहां पे मुझे टॉप पोर्ट्स स्कैन करनी है
ठीक है एंड यहां पे मुझे फुल 1000 10000
जो भी नंबर्स से आप दे सकते हैं ठीक है जो
भी जितने भी पोर्ट्स आपको स्कैन करनी है
तो मैं यहां करता हूं सेम एल हा ये कर
देता हूं न टीपी टॉप पोर्ट्स के लिए एंड
यहां पे मैं कर देता हूं अ 1000 कर देते
हैं तो एंटर कर देते हैं अब ये पर्टिकुलर
1000 जो पोर्ट्स है उसको स्कैन करेगा एंड
आपको रिजल्ट्स देगा अगर कोई पोर्ट
पर्टिकुलर ओपन है इस पर्टिकुलर होस्ट के
ऊपर तब ठीक है तो ये भी तो यहां पे कोई सी
भी नहीं है 8443 है तो आपको 8443 ही मिल
जाएगा जी हां एक्टिव पोर्ट्स बिल्कुल
बिल्कुल एब्सलूट तो यहां पे आपको मिल
जाएगा उसी तरीके से अब अब आपको इसको यूज
करने के बहुत सारे तरीके हैं जैसे कि हमने
एक सिंपल सा वे देख लिया ये चीज अब यहां
पे आप देखिए यहां पे नीचे आते
हैं लेट्स कम डाउन लेट्स कम डाउन लेट्स कम
डाउन हियर
हियर हां अब लिस्ट ऑफ होस्ट अगर आपको आपके
पास है जैसे आईपी एड्रेसस की पूरी लिस्ट
है तो उसके ऊपर भी आप नाबू चला सकते हैं
पर्टिकुलर पोर्ट्स के लिए आप फिल्टर कर
सकते हैं कि पर्टिकुलर पोर्ट्स कोई है
जिसको आप स्कैन करना चाहते हैं बस सिंपल
सा फंडा है और कुछ भी नहीं है तो आप एसए
नंबर भी डाल सकते हैं ठीक है तो यह क्या
करेगा रन एसए को इनपुट लेगा एंड आईपी
एड्रेसस जो अवेलेबल है इस एए के लिए उस पे
पोर्ट स्कैनिंग कर देगा सिंपल या तो आप
डायरेक्टली नाबू नफन l host.txt ऐसे चला
सकते हैं तो अगर हम ऐसे चलाएंगे तो सिंपल
सा तरीका है
नाबू न
h लिस्ट के लिए हान l दे देंगे तो नाबू न
एल एल की हमारे पास एल आईपी ऑलरेडी पड़ी
हुई है एंड ट्स इट एंटर करेंगे अब देखिए
यहां पर ये होस्ट डिस्कवरी स्कैन स्टार्ट
कर
देगा लेट्स
वेट
स्टार्टेड
यहां पे आप फर्द और भी आर्गुमेंट लगा सकते
हैं फिलहाल हमने बहुत ही सिंपल सा
आर्गुमेंट लगाया है जो यहां पे आपके यहां
पे सिंपल लिस्ट ऑफ होस्ट के लिए हम कर
सकते हैं यहां पे अगर आपको इसमें भी
पर्टिकुलर होस्ट लिस्ट ऑफ होस्ट में भी
आपको अगर एक पर्टिकुलर पोर्ट के लिए चाहिए
तो आप हान p या हान पोर्ट ऐसे लगा सकते
हैं फिलहाल हम यहां पे बेसिकली यहां पे
पूरी ही हमने चला दिया यहां पे ऑलमोस्ट
सारी ही पोर्ट्स के लिए ब डिफॉल्ट हमने
चला दिया जो डिफॉल्ट टूल है हमारा जो भी
डिफॉल्ट इसका ऑप्शन है अब लेट्स सी लेट्स
वेट फॉर द रिजल्ट शुड बी गिविंग रिजल्ट्स
इन फ्यू
मोमेंट्स या फिर हम इसमें मेंशन कर सकते
हैं कोई पर्टिकुलर अगर आपको मेंशन करना है
तो वी कैन मेंशन इट राइट लाइक दैट हाइन प
एंड यहां पर हम 80 एंड 443 मेंशन कर देते
दो पोर्ट्स ए लेट्स
सी वेट इ य र प एंड 8 443 तो हमने दो
पोर्ट्स के लिए यहां पे कर दिया है लेट्स
वेट फॉर द
रिजल्ट सो इट्स
रनिंग एंड हमें कुछ यहां पे आया नहीं हमें
कुछ यहां पे हमें कुछ भी मिला नहीं इसका
मतलब है कोई भी 8443 वाली आईपी नहीं होंगी
लाइक पोर्ट नहीं होंगी बिकॉज हमने देखा भी
था कि कोई ओपन पोर्ट यहां पे अवेलेबल नहीं
था अ जो हमने एंग्री आईपीए स्कैनर से
स्कैन किया था वी डिन गेट एनी ओपन पोर्ट
राइट हमें कुछ ओपन पोर्ट मिला नहीं था
इसलिए हमें यहां पे कुछ मिला ही नहीं है
सिंपल सा फंडा है तो हमें ये तो हम एक
पर्टिकुलर रेंज के लिए कर दिया अब मान लो
यहां पे हम एलएस करते हैं
apple.id यहां पे अब हम इसको एक और भी
सीआईडीआर रेंज को पकड़ सकते हैं एंड उसके
ऊपर भी हम चला सकते हैं सीआईडीआर मैप उससे
आईपी निकाल सकते हैं और उसको हम डाल सकते
हैं फिल्टर आउट कर सकते हैं तो कैट एल
सीआईडीआर कैट किया हमने हम इसमें कोई एक
और आईपी रेंज ले लेते हैं ठीक
है लेट्स टेक सम मोर आईपी रेंजेस यर मतलब
मैं एक यह वाला भी ले लेता हूं इस तरीके
से ले सकते हैं
हालाकि और 17 और लेट्स लीव 17 लेट्स गो टू
सम
57 यह वाली ले लेते हैं यह वाली राइट इसको
ले लेते हैं यहां मैप सीआईडीआर हाइन
सीआईडीआर य हमने दे दिया एंड यहां पर हम
यहां पर पेस्ट कर देते हैं एंड लेट्स सी द
रिजल्ट हाउ मेनी आईपी वी आर गेटिंग लेट्स
काउंट डलसी l तो यहां पे 2000 आईपी आ रही
है ठीक है अब यहां पे हम इसको एक फाइल में
डाल देते हैं अ
apple.tv यहां पे आ चुकी है सेम कमांड में
यहां पे एक बार ट्राई करते हैं इसके ऊपर
में शायद इसमें कुछ मिल जाए आपको मे बी तो
लेट्स गिव इट अ फाइल नेम टी एकटी एंड
दैट्ची है नहीं है तो यहां पे भी आपको कुछ
नहीं मिलती है तो यू हैव टू स्कैन मतलब
आपको स्कैन करना है एंड यू मस्ट अ गेट सम
रिजल्ट्स आउट ऑफ इट राइट कुछ नाना कुछ
आपको इंटरेस्टिंग रिजल्ट्स आपको मिल
जाएंगे तो आप बहुत बड़ी रेंज आपको आईपी की
अगर आपके पास है बहुत सारे आईपी रेंजेस
हैं तो आप इन टूल्स का यूज़ कर सकते हैं
जैसे जैसे मैं नाबू का यूज कर रहा हूं या
और भी जो भी टूल्स आप उसको यूज कर सकते
यूटिलाइज कर सकते हो राइट अब यहां पे यहां
पे नाबू को तो हमने यूज किया किसलिए यूज
किया अब चलो एक बहुत बड़ी फाइल है उसके
साथ भी यूज कर सकते हैं नाबू को तो नाबू
जैसे हम थोड़े कुछ ऑप्शन मिक्स कर सकते
हैं जैसे हमने एल आईड t एक्टी यूज कर लिया
अब एल आड t एकटी के साथ साथ यहां पर हम
थोड़ा सा रेट बढ़ा देंगे हान रेट इसकी
हेल्प फाइल मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं इसमें
सारा कुछ मेंशन है
न तो ना न ए एल आईपीटी एक्टी उसका थोड़ा
सा रेट इंक्रीज कर देंगे 3000 इसकी जो
स्पीड है ऊपर में देखिए यहां पर आपको रेट
मिल
[संगीत]
जाएगा द
रेट यह वाली
आपको रिज्यूम करना है तो ठीक है जस्ट वेट
जस्ट वेट जस्ट
वेट ओके ये रहा हाइन रेट तो पैकेज टू से
डिफॉल्ट 1000 है इसको हमने 3000 कर दिया
है तो हमें यहां पे रेट हमने इंक्रीज कर
दिया इसका अब हम यहां पे इसका हाइन
रिट्राईंग जो कि डिफॉल्ट तीन होता है यहां
पे अगर आप जाएंगे
रिट्री कैन सी
हियर वयर इट इज वयर इट इज वयर इट इज
ट्राइज कहां है भैया ट्राइज
यह रहा ट्राइज नंबर ऑफ ट्राइज फॉर द पोर्ट
स्कन डिफॉल्ट तीन है तो इसको हम वन कर
देते हैं उसके बाद वार्म अप टाइम जो है
टाइम इन सेकंड्स बिटवीन द स्कैन फेजस तो
डिफॉल्ट टू है तो इसको हम वर्म अप टाइम
हमें नहीं चाहिए तो मैं क्या कर देता हूं
रिइज वन उसके बाद हाइ फन वर्म
अप टाइम इसको मैं जीरो कर देता हूं वर्म
अप टाइम हमें नहीं चाहिए सो वी आर जस्ट
रिड्यूस द वर्म अप टाइम टू जीरो एंड यहां
पे
हम रेट लिमिट के लिए हाइन सी यूज कर लेते
हैं जनरल इंटरनल वर्कर थ्रेड तो डिफॉल्ट
25 है तो हाइन सी के लिए हम 50 यूज कर
लेते हैं ट्स इट बस इतना करेंगे आप एंटर
कर सकते हैं एंड वी कैन सी द रिजल्ट्स
राइट लेट्स सी इफ वी आर गेटिंग सम
रिजल्ट्स
आई डोंट थिंक सो कि हमें कोई ऐसी कोई
रिजल्ट मिलेगी साईपी
पे हम यहां पर टॉप टॉप पोर्ट्स को भी
स्कैन कर सकते हैं जो भी टॉप पोर्ट्स है
उसको स्कैन कर सकते
हैं
वी डॉट गेट नथिंग यहां पर हम हाइन टॉप
हाइन पोर्ट्स लगा के एंड यहां पे पोर्ट्स
को स्कैन कर सकते हैं फुल तो जो भी फुल है
वह जो भी रिजल्ट्स है में फुल जो भी
स्कैनिंग करेगा यह पोर्ट्स के लिए वह हमें
यहां पर रिजल्ट प्रोवाइड करेगा तो इसमें
थोड़ा सा टाइम आपको लग सकता है बिकॉज हमने
टॉप पोर्ट्स को फुल स्कैन किया है सो इट
माइट डिपेंड्स ऑन द इंटरनेट कनेक्शन ऑन द
नेटवर्क स्पीड ऑफ
तो आपके लोकल सिस्टम पर यह काफी स्लो वैसे
भी काम करेगा बट अगर आप वीपीएस वगैरह यूज
कर रहे हैं तो इट शुड बी कंपेरटिवली वेरी
फास्ट ठीक
है नमस्ते इटस
डी ओके लेट
सी लेटस सी इसके बाद और भी ट जो तरीके हैं
मैं आपको बताऊंगा अभी देखते जाइए अभी तो
बहुत कुछ है अभी देखते
जाइए देर आर मल्टीपल
वेज ओ सीआईडीआर वाली फाइल भी मैं डाउनलोड
कर लेता
हूं
आई थिंक डाउनलोड हो गई क्या एल सीआईडीआर
हा ठीक है डाउनलोड हो गई है चलिए अच्छी
बात
है रनिंग द
स्कन इसको स्कैन होने देते
हैं ठीक है इसको स्कैन हो देते हैं अब यह
जो है हम नाबू को सॉरी नाबू एक बहुत ही
फास्ट पोर्ट स्कैनर है तो हम इसको यूज कर
रहे हैं यहां पर अब जो पोर्ट्स हमें ओपन
मिलेंगे ना हम उस पर एन मैप चला सकते हैं
वी कैन ट्राई टू रन n m ऑन दैट इवन नाबू
के अंदर हम n मैप चला सकते हैं यह हमें एक
फैसिलिटी मिलता है नाबू के अंदर नाबू
इसमें इनबिल्ट आपको दिया गया है एज़ अ
कमांड आप ए मैप का यूज़ कर सकते हैं तो
फिलहाल हम फुल पोर्ट स्कैनिंग कर रहे हैं
तो यहां पे आपको थोड़ा वेट करना
पड़ेगा यहां पे आप न v लगा दीजिएगा तो
आपको वर्वस जो आउटपुट है वह आपको जो भी
चीज़ें हो रही है वह आपको दिखेगी भी यहां
पे यह आपको दिख रहा है रिसीवड आईसीएमपी
स्पैम अ आईसी आईसीएमपी रिस्पांस यह देख
सकते हैं आप यहां
पे
सॉरी सो वी आर गेटिंग द रिस्पांस हियर
फ्रॉम दीज टारगेट्स मासी प रिस्पांस मिल
रही
है अ यहां पे फर्द आपकी चल रही है
प्रोसेस
यस यस बिल्कुल आप आईपी के ऊपर भी बिल्कुल
आप कर सकते हैं टारगेट आईपी को भी आप
टारगेट एस अ टारगेट लेकर चल सकते
हैं यहां पर इसका रिस्पांस आएगा थोड़ा
टाइम लगेगा ओबवियसली तो इसको हम अभी होने
देते हैं ऐसे ही बैकग्राउंड में ठीक है
ओके तो इस तरीके से आप एनम का यूज सॉरी इस
तर से आप नाबू का यूज कर सकते हैं नाबू के
बाद एक और बहुत ही शानदार टूल है जिसको हम
यूज करने वाले हैं एंड दैट इज नोन एज मास
स्कैन अब ये बहुत ही शानदार टूल है बहुत
खतरनाक टूल है ये एक मास आईपी पोर्ट
स्कैनर टूल है अब यहां देखो ये इंटरनेट
स्केल का पोर्ट स्कैनर है पूरे इंटरनेट को
ये देखो यहां
पे इट कैन स्कैन द
एंटायस 5 मिनट्स ट्रांसमिटिंग 10 मिलियन
पैकेट्स पर सेकंड फ्रॉम अ सिंगल मशीन इतना
पावर फुल मास स्कैन जो टूल है एंड मास
स्कैन का खुद का एडहॉक टीसीपी आईपी स्टैक
है
दैट्ची है अब यहां पे मैं यहां पे आप दे
यहां पे इसको मैं क्लोज़ कर देता हूं
फिलहाल इस पे आते हैं यहां पे एटलेस्ट मास
कैन लेट्स सी इफ देयर इज़ नो नो नो नो
नहीं है
चलिए इस तरीके से आप इसको इंस्टॉल कर सकते
हैं सिंपल अब इसको रन करने के लिए क्या
आपको कैसे रन करना है बहुत ही सिंपल है
आपके पास एक रेंज है आईपी की रेंज है बस
उसी तरीके से जैसे ए मैप चलाया जाता है
वैसे ही चला सकते हैं आप मास स्कैन हान एच
कर दीजिएगा इसकी हेल्प फाइल आ जाएगी कुछ
इस तरीके से आप इसको यूज करेंगे मास
स्कैन ठीक है अब यहां पर पोर्ट कौन सी
पोर्ट को आपको स्कैन करना है सिंपल इसके
लिए आप आपके पास एक चीटशीट में अवेलेबल
करवा दूंगा एंड यह चीटशीट
है यह वाली चीटशीट ठीक है यह चीट शीट है
यह आपको मैं अवेलेबल करवा दूंगा प के अंदर
भी मैं इसको डाउनलोड करके वहां पर अपलोड
कर दूंगा आप वहां से कर सकते हैं इसको यूज
एंड सिंपल अगर आपको एक आईपी को स्कैन करनी
है तो इस तरीके से एक टारगेट आईपी रेंज को
करनी है तो इस तरीके से आप कर सकते हैं
मल्टीपल रेंज को आप कर सकते हैं आईपी फाइल
है कोई आपके
पास जिसको एक्सक्लूड करना है तो आप इस
तरीके से कर सकते हैं ठीक है उसके बाद
यहां पे आप अ कुछ और भी तरीके यूज़ कर
सकते हैं जैसे रेट आप इसका जो है बढ़ा
सकते हैं यहां पे जैसे हान हान रेट जो है
10000 है यहां पे यहां पे अ रेट आप बढ़ा
के थोड़ा और भी फास्ट आप कर सकते हैं यह
सारी काम आप कर सकते हैं फिलहाल के लिए हम
क्या कर देते हैं h p 80 एंड 80 से ले 80
कर देते हैं 80 एंड 443 ही कर लेते हैं 80
एंड 443 कर लेते हैं ठीक है दो पोर्ट के
लिए हम यहां पे अ चलते हैं 80 पोर्ट 80
एंड 443 के लिए ठीक है तो इस तरीके से यू
कैन जस्ट गो एंड जस्ट चेक आउट डिफरेंट
डिफरेंट काइंस ऑफ पोर्ट्स जो भी पोर्ट्स
आप देना चाहते हैं वो आप पोस्ट दीजिए तो
हम यहां पे हान p के साथ 80n 443 दे देते
हैं ठीक है चलिए अ सो लेट्स न p
8443 एंड यहां पे एक सीआईडी रेंज दे देते
हैं चलिए एक सीआईडी रेंज कोई सा भी एल का
ले लेते हैं लेट्स टेक दिस दिस रेंज कॉपी
इट लेट्स पेस्ट इट
यहां पे हमने पेज दे दिया एंड यहां पे
हमने हाईफा रेट इज इक्वल टू 10000 ही कर
दिया एंटर कर देंगे जैसे ही आप एंटर
करेंगे इट विल स्टार्ट स्कैनिंग आप देख
सकते हैं यहां पे स्कैनिंग जो है वो चल
रही है बिल्कुल अच्छे से एंड यहां प 100%
डन हो चुका है
[संगीत]
एंड यहां पे आपको रिजल्ट्स जो है वो मिल
चुका है यहां पे आपको रिजल्ट्स में कुछ
खास मिला नहीं स्कैनिंग 4096 होस्ट को
स्कैन किया इसने एंड वी डिंट गेट एनीथिंग
आउट ऑफ इट तो हमें कुछ ऐसा कुछ खास मिला
नहीं है राइट तो अब यहां
पे
8 आप पोर्ट की रेंज भी दे सकते हैं लाइक
इफ यू वांट टू स्कैन अ पोर्ट रेंज तो आप
पोर्ट रेंज भी दे सकते हैं जैसे हान p दे
दिया हम मुझे पूरा पोर्ट स्कैन करना है
जीरो से लेके
65535 मुझे पूरी ही पोर्ट स्कैन कर देनी
है इस पर्टिकुलर रेंज के लिए तो मैं ये
वाला कमांड चला दूंगा ठीक है और इसके
साथ-साथ मैं यहां पे क्या करता हूं मैं
सीआईडीआर चेंज कर देता हूं लेट्स चेंज द
सीआईडीआर लेट्स गिव अ ह्यूज ब्लॉक ऑफ
सीआईडीआर रेंज चलिए मैं यहां पे 17 को
छोड़ के आई एम गिविंग द फर्स्ट आईपी दिस
वन लेट्स प्रोवाइड दिस
वन ठीक है एंड लेट्स प्रेस द एंटर की एंड
लेट्स सी द मैजिक तो यह देखिए यहां पर
यहां पर मैं थोड़ा सा और बड़ स्पीड जो है
ना वो इंक्रीज कर देता हूं थोड़ा सा स्पीड
इंक्रीज करूंगा मैं यहां पर 10000 की जगह
पर यहां प 50000 कर देता हूं एंड लेट्स
एंटर एंड लेट्स सी क्या होता है यह तो सेम
कमांड आ यह वाली तो यहां पर 50000 कर देते
हैं और एंटर करते
हैं चलिए नाउ लेट्स सी ये आप देख सकते हैं
बहुत ही ज्यादा यहां पर होस्ट जो है ना यह
इतने सारे आईपॉड्स के लिए इसको स्कैन कर
रहा है टोटली एंड यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं
अभी तक 0.01 पर क्योंकि बहुत ज्यादा बड़ी
ये होस्ट लिस्ट है बेसिकली तो यहां पे ये
स्कैनिंग चालू हो चुकी है एंड जो भी
पोर्ट्स ओपन पोर्ट्स हैं आपको ये सिंपल
आपको यहां पे लाके दे देगा तो हमने पूरी
ही पोर्ट के लिए यहां पे कर दिया यहां पे
कुछ ज्यादा ही पोर्ट के लिए हमने कर दिया
है तो हम इसको यहां पे पोर्ट को थोड़ा सा
कम कर सकते हैं लाइक रो से लेके
1023 तक कर सकते हैं जो हमारे वेल नोन
पोर्ट्स उनके लिए स्कैन कर सकते हैं लेट्स
सी सो इट्स मूविंग अ लिटिल बिट फास्टर देन
अलिर बिकॉज पोर्ट्स की हमने वो कम कर दी
है
[संगीत]
तो यहां पर यह स्कैनिंग स्टार्ट कर चुका
है ना इट विल गिव यू एनी ओपन पोर्ट
प्रेजेंट कोई भी ओपन पोर्ट इसको मिलता है
तो य आपको प्रोवाइड करेगा
राइट क्या इशू आ गई
भाई सेम आईपीस कैसे होंगे यार नहीं होंगे
ना यूनिक आईपी होती है ना इनकी खुद की तो
कहां सेम होंगे है
ना इसको थोड़ा चलने देते हैं लेट्स रन इट
थोड़ा सा रन होने देते हैं
भैया
ठीक हैय आप नाबू में भी आप पोर्ट को
डिफाइन कर सकते हो जैसे मैंने आपको बताया
यू कैन डिफाइन द पोर्ट्स इ नाबू
ल्स तो सोचो यह वीपीएस पर अगर इस तरीके से
चल रहा है सोचो आप लोकल मशीन पर चलाओगे तो
इसमें कितना टाइम लगेगा खुद
सोचो क्लासेस के बीच में गैप इसलिए दी
जाती है थोड़ी कि कुछ लोग लाइक पीछे हो
जाते हैं ना बैक बैक में चलते हैं तो वो
थोड़ा कैचप कर ले और थोड़ा रिवाइज करने का
टाइम मिले प्रैक्टिस करने का टाइम मिले
क्योंकि इतना कुछ हो गया है ना कि अगर आप
उसको प्रैक्टिस करोगे तो आप सोचोगे सर
इतना कम टाइम है सर थोड़ा और टाइम दे दो
थोड़ा और टाइम दे दो इस तरीके से आपके
दिमाग में आएगा याद
रखिएगा तो यह काम आप कर लेंगे क्योंकि
इसमें टाइम लगेगा तो मैं बहुत पूरा एंड तक
नहीं जा रहा हूं मैं बस आपको सिखा रहा हूं
कि कैसे आप मास्क स्कैन का यूज कर सकते
हैं नाबू का यूज कर सकते हैं मैप सीआईडीआर
का यूज कर सकते हैं एसएन मैप का यूज कर
सकते हैं किस तरीके से एंग्री आईपी स्कैनर
से स्कैन कर सकते हैं सीआईडीआर को कैसे से
पास आउट कर सकते हैं इस तरीके से यू कैन
यूटिलाइज राइट तो अब इसी तरीके का इसको आप
स्कैन कर
लीजिएगा ठीक है गॉट इट स्कैन करते रहिएगा
आपको रिजल्ट्स मिलेंगे कहीं कहीं कुछ ओपन
पोर्ट मिलता है तो आप उसको ए मैप से फिर
सर्विस के लिए भी चेक आउट कर सकते हैं
राइट अब मैं आपको एक चीज दिखाता
हूं मैं आपको यहां पे एक चीज दिखाता हूं
मैंने एलएस किया यहां पे और मेरे पास यहां
पे app2
txt.gz
हां जी तो अब मेरे पास यह तो हो गया चलो
पॉज रिजूम ड सीएफजी य फाइल बन जाती है
इसकी रिज्यूम फाइल है इसलिए टेंशन मत
लीजिएगा जहां से आपने स्टॉप किया वहीं से
रिज्यूम कर सकते स्कैन को अब इसके बाद एक
टूल और है जो बहुत ही शानदार टूल है दैट
इज नोन एज रस्ट
स्कैन चलिए तो रस्ट रस्ट स्कैन की तरफ
चलते हैं वेर इट इज वी यूज द मास्क स्कैन
लेट्स रन रस्ट स्कन रस्ट स्कन
चलिए यह भी एक टूल
है इसको मॉडर्न पोर्ट स्कैनर बोलते हैं रस
स्कैन को हम मॉडर्न पोर्ट स्कैनर बोलते
हैं इसका रीजन है मैं आपको सीधा-सीधा यहां
पर बताता हूं सिंपल इसके इंस्टॉलेशन का
बहुत ही सिंपल तरीका है यहां पर आप
इंस्टॉलेशन गाइड प आ जाइएगा यहां पर आपको
इंस्टॉलेशन
की पूरी गाइड जो है वह मिल जाएगी बेसिकली
यहां पे एंड हियर यू कैन इंस्टॉल इट एज अ
डॉकर डॉकर की तरह आप इसको रन कर सकते हैं
एलिस बना के आप सिंपल एक कमांड से इसको रन
कर सकते हैं या तो आप सिंपली बिल्ड कर
सकते हैं डॉका बिल्ड करके या तो आप डेवियन
काली में है तो आप इसका डीपी केजी जो
पैकेज है वह आप इसको वो इंस्टॉल कर सकते
हैं अ या तो ी कैन यू कैन सिंपली गिट
क्लोन करके उस फोल्डर में जाके एंड वो काम
कर सकते हैं बिल्ड आप खुद से करना चाहते
हैं तो गिट क्लोन कीजिए रस्ट को इंस्टॉल
कीजिए इस वाले कमांड से रस इंस्टॉल कर
लीजिए पहले देन आप इस गेट हब रिपोजिटरी
में जाइए कार्गो बिल्ड रिलीज यह कमांड
चलाइए देन आप आपका एक बिन फाइल के अंदर
रिलीज वर्जन जो है आ जाएगा आपके यह वाले
फोल्डर में टारगेट रिलीज में और इसको आप
यूजर बिन में प्लेस कर दीजिए स्ल यूर स्
बिन में प्लेस कर दीजिए एंड आप इसको
डायरेक्टली स्कैन मतलब इसको स्टार्ट कर
सकते हैं आप रस्ट स्कैन को चला सकते हैं
तो यहां पे मेरा ऑलरेडी यहां पे रस्ट
स्कैन और डन है तो मैं यहां पे इसकी हेल्प
फाइल ओपन कर लेता हूं एक बार एंड जब मैं
इसकी हेल्प फाइल ओपन करूंगा तो आपको यहां
पे दिखेगा बहुत सिंपल सा छोटा सा हेल्प
फाइल आपको दिखता है तो यहां पे आपको एक
एक्सेसिबल मोड दिखता है यहां पे एक ग्रेबल
मोड दिखता है ये मोड्स के ऊपर हम बात
करेंगे एक्सेसिबल मोड क्या होता है टर्न
ऑफ फीचर्स व्हिच नेगेटिवली अफेक्ट स्क्रीन
रीडर्स ग्रैपे बल मोड ओनली आउटपुट द
पोर्ट्स नो ए मैप ए मैप इस पे नहीं चलता
है जब रस स्कैन चलाते हो तो इसपे ए मैप
नहीं चलेगा ग्रेपल मोड में ठीक है तो हमें
सिंपल सा काम करना है हमें बहुत ज्यादा
कुछ अ अ लाइक दिमाग नहीं लगाना हमें
एक्सेसिबल मोड ही चला हम या तो एक्सेसिबल
मोड में चला सकते हैं ग्रैपे बल आपकी
मर्जी है फिलहाल के लिए क्या होता है हान
ए ऑप्शन का आप यूज कर सकते हैं एक कॉमा
डीलिमिटेड लिस्ट और न्यू लाइन लिमिटेड
फाइल ऑफ सेपरेटेड सीआईडीआर या आईपी तो
यहां पे आप आईपी या सीआईडीआर की रेंज डाल
सकते हो जिस पर भी आप स्कैन करना चाहते हो
तो मैं क्या करूंगा यहां पे रस्ट स्कैन
करूंगा हान ए दूंगा और यहां पे मैं
एल एल आईपी t एकटी ये वाली फाइल पास कर
दूंगा ठीक है ये काम इतना आपको समझ में आ
गया होगा सिंपल रकन h a एल और इसके बाद
यहां पे आप यू लिमिट लगा सकते हैं ठीक है
ना यू लिमिट लगा के ऑटोमेटिक अप्स द य
लिमिट विद द वैल्यू प्रोवाइडेड तो हम यहां
पर हाइन य लगा के इसकी लिमिट को थोड़ा सा
बढ़ाने की कोशिश करेंगे 10000 कर देते हैं
एंड ट्स इट अब हम एंटर करेंगे और वेट
करेंगे कि हमें कुछ मिलता है कि नहीं
मिलता है सो इट्स
स्कैनिंग ट्राइट
स्कैन कुछ मिलेगा तो ओबवियसली इट विल गिव
इट विल आउटपुट यू
राइट नट गेट एनीथिंग
यट कुछ भी हमें अभी तक मिला नहीं
है
नथिंग व गेटिंग नथिंग
हियर तो बेसिकली ये स्कैन करेगा एंड आपको
रिजल्ट्स शो करेगा कुछ इस तरीके से जैसे
कोई ओपन पोर्ट आपको कहीं से कुछ मिलता है
कुछ इसको ओपन पोर्ट टाइप कुछ मिलता है तो
ये आपको यहां पर लिस्ट करके देगा यहां प
सिंपली आपको यहां पे ये दिखा देगा जैसे
मैं आपको यहां पे एग्जांपल में दिखा देता
हूं किस तरीके से ये दिखाएगा आप एक बार
देख लीजिए ताकि आपको आईडिया लग जाए जैसे
इस तरीके से यह जो रन हो रही है यहां पे
आप देखिए यहां पे इट्स रनिंग इट्स रनिंग
एंड यहां पे देखो एंड यहां पे ये जैसे ही
ओपन इस तरीके से ओपन पोर्ट जो है वो
दिखाएगा आपको ठीक है जैसे ये बेसिकली
google.com पे कर रहे हैं यहां पे तो आप
एक पर्टिकुलर टारगेट के लिए भी आप ट्राई
आउट कर सकते हो अगर किसी टारगेट के लिए
ट्राई आउट करना चाहते हो तो वो भी आप
ट्राई आउट कर सकते हो एक लिस्ट भी दे सकते
हो तो कहने का मतलब है यहां पे अ यू कैन
सिंपली यूज कुछ इस तरीके
से कुछ इस तरीके से रस्ट स्कैन एंड जो
आपका टारगेट है वो एंड उसके बाद हाइफान
हाफ नो ए मैप अगर ए मैप आपको नहीं यूज
करना है अनलिमिट आप आप बढ़ा दीजिए वो करके
भी आप कर सकते हैं जैसे रस्ट स्कैन एंड
यहां पे हम ने दे दिया टेस्ला कॉ य हमने
ला कॉ के लिए दे दिया एंड उसके बाद हान य
[संगीत]
एंड ओके देर
समथिंग ओके हान यू लिमिट य पर हमने दे
दिया एंड हमने यू लिमिट में इसका यू लिमिट
क्या कर देते
हैं हान हान है ना ओके हान य कर देते
10000 एंड नो ए मैप हान नो हान एंड मैप
कोई ए मैप ना चले एंड लेट्स सी वट इ
हैपनिंग व्ट
हैपेंड आरवी गिविंग द करेक्टर हियर र
कैन ओके लेट्स सी लेट्स चेक
ओके तो हम यहां पे शायद इन्होंने वो चीज
डायरेक्टली एक्सेस जो है वो चीज कर दी हटा
दी है ठीक है कोई बात नहीं कोई इशू नहीं
है कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है हम डायरेक्टली
लिस्ट ऑफ होस्ट ही दे देंगे कोई दिक्कत
नहीं आपके पास अगर होस्ट लिस्ट है तो आप
वो दे सकते हैं रस्ट स्कैन आपने कर दिया
हान एच यहां प आप लिस्ट दे सकते हैं जैसे
कि यहां पे आप देखिए
अ यह रहा कॉमी अ ये कॉमा डे लिमटेड लिस्ट
ऑफ सेपरेटेड सीआईडीआर आईपीस और होस्ट्स टू
बी स्कैंड ठीक है तो आप पर्टिकुलर होस्ट
एक रेंज दे सकते हैं और कुछ भी नहीं है
यहां पे तो आप रे अगर आप एक होस्ट की
लिस्ट देना चाहते हैं तो यू कैन प्रोवाइड
द होस्ट लिस्ट
दैट्ची
टेस्ला
कॉ ट्स इट मैं यहां पर टेस्ला कॉ कर देता
हूं सेम कमांड में यहां पर मैं हान ए करके
एंड होस्टड एक्सटी डाल देता हूं एंड नो ए
मैप करके एंटर कर देता हूं
लाट ओके नॉट
गेटिंग व्ट इ
हैपनिंग ओके हान ए हमने लगाया था क्या हा
हमने लगाया ना होस्टड ठीक है आन य भी
लगाया नो ए मैप रिमूव कर देते एक बार
लेट्स ट्राई यस तो यहां पे नो एन मैप जो
है वो चीज डिप्रेशिएट हो गई है तो हम यहां
प डायरेक्टली जो है होस्ट प यहां प चला
रहे हैं एंड लेट्स सी व्ट इज
हैपनिंग हमारा एक टारगेट है
[संगीत]
tesla.svs
सॉरी तो यहां पे हमें ओपन पोर्ट मिली एक
आईपी मिली जिस पे ये ओपन पोर्ट यहां पे
ओपन पोर्ट आपको मिलता है
दैट्ची और ये यही यही दो आईपीस जो है व
हमें मिली है जिसके जिसम पोर्ट्स जो है
ओपन है यहां पे सो वी कैन जस्ट कॉपी इट
जस्ट ट्राई टू एक्सेस इट व्हाट इज
देयर इनवेलिड यू आर लेट्स डू अ हु इज ऑन
दिस हु इज ऑन दिस
आईपी सो आका माई टेक्नोलॉजी ठीक है दिस इज
आका माई टेक्नोलॉजी ओके डन गट इट
या तो यमाई टेक्नोलॉजी का ये आईपी है तो
यह हमें पता चल गया सिंपल इस आईपी पे आप
फर्द जो है एन मैप भी कर सकते हैं इफ यू
वांट यू कैन डू एन मैप ऑन इट ए मैप 5 एवी
एंड इफ यू वांट हालांकि यह आईपी इस पे
आपको कुछ मिलेगा नहीं बट स्टिल इफ यू वांट
टू ट्राई यू कैन जस्ट गो एंड गो अहेड एंड
ट्राई इट राइट नाबू के साथ भी आप इसको यूज
ए मैप को कमांड को यूज कर सकते हैं नाबू
के अंदर एक फीचर है जैसे आपने नाबू को आप
यह चीज कर सकते हैं जैसे आप क्या करोगे
नाबू यहां पे आपने नाबू कि हान h अब देखो
यहां पे लिस्ट दे दे सकते हो तुम होस्ट की
नाबू में न एल से लिस्ट ऑफ होस्ट स्कैन
ठीक है तो हमने क्या किया नाबू न l एंड
यहां पे हमने दे दिया host.txt
एक तो
सिंपल अब यहां पे पोर्ट्स के लिए तो हाइन
टॉप पोर्ट्स को स्कैन करना है तो हाइ फन
टॉप पोर्ट्स लगा दो या फिर हान पोर्ट्स
लगा दो एंड 8443 केलिए कर दो 443
दैट्ची कैन इंक्लूड द ए मैप कमांड तो मैं
अगर ए मैप कमांड यूज करूं तो हान n मैप स
लगा के और n मैप की कोई सी भी कमांड में
चला सकता हूं ठीक है तो यहां पे मैं न n m
न अ स ये लगा दिया एंड सिंगल कोड के अंदर
n मैप एंड जो आपका कमांड है न एवी ये
कमांड आपने लगा दी और एंटर कर दिया तो
बेसिकली ये होस्ट डिस्कवरी तो आपका चलाएगा
ही चलाएगा इस पर्टिकुलर पोर्ट के लिए एंड
उसके बाद ये ए मैप भी चला देगा जो भी आपका
ये पर्टिकुलर जो भी ओपन पोर्ट मिलेगा तो
यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं कि यहां पे आपका
n मैप भी स्टार्ट हो चुका है राइट सो इट्स
गिविंग यू द आउटपुट ऑफ एंड मैप आल्सो तो
आप इसको नाबू के साथ इस तरीके से कनेक्ट
कर सकते हो तो अब आपको यहां पे एन मैप
मिला यहां पे दो है एटीटीपी आमाई आमाई
होस्ट है ल यहां पे आपका आका माय होस्ट है
और कुछ यहां पे कुछ खास यहां पे मिला नहीं
तो यू गट द यहां पे रिजल्ट्स बस
दैट्ची जें क्लियर हो गई होंगी अब जो भी
आईपी रो अब देखो क्या करना
है कलेक्ट ऑल
द आईपीस विथ ओपन पोर्ट्स और ओपन पोर्ट्स
यही करना है सेकंड रन सर्विस
वर्जन
डिटेक्शन वाया एन मैप एन मैप का यूज करके
आप सर्विस वर्जन डिटेक्शन आप चलाइए इस पर
ठीक है तो यह क्या करेगा सर्विस के वर्जन
को डिटेक्ट करने की कोशिश करेगा एंड देन
ट्राई
टू ट्राई टू गेट एक्सेस
टू दैट पोर्ट टू दैट
सर्विस और एक्सप्लोइट इट और एक्सप्लोइट इट
बस यही तो काम करना है पूरे एक टारगेट को
चूज करके विथ ओपन पोर्ट्स ऑफ द टारगेट एक
टारगेट चूज कीजिए उसके जितने आईपी है
कलेक्ट कीजिए बहुत सारे ऑप्शंस मैंने आपको
बता दिए कैसे कलेक्ट करना है नाबू का लाइक
एन मैप का यूज कीजिए मैप स सीआईडीआर का
यूज कीजिए उसके बाद आप नाबू यूज कीजिए आप
रस स्कैन यूज कीजिए मास्क स्कैन यूज कीजिए
बहुत सारे टूल्स है यूज कीजिए आई को
कलेक्ट करके एक जगह पर रखिए उसके बाद
डीएनए डीएनएस एक्स आप चला के यहां पे और
उसकी डोमेन नेम फाइंड करने की कोशिश कीजिए
जो उसे पर्टिकुलर एसोसिएटेड डोमेन है फिर
उसके ऊपर एन मैप आप चला सकते हैं या जो
पर्टिकुलर आईपी है जिसमें ओपन पोर्ट्स
आपको मिलते हैं उसपे एन मैप आप चला सकते
हैं एंड यू कैन गेट एक्सेस टू द सर्विस जो
अगर कर पा रहे हैं एक्सप्लोइट कर पा रहे
हैं देन
दैट्ची क्लियर
गाइस चलिए मुझे बता दीजिए जल्दी से फटाफट
फटाफट बताइए य तक सबका क्लियर
है वेरी गुड कंटेंट थैंक यू थैंक यू मेरा
फेवरेट टूल है चलो अच्छी बात
है रिवर्स आईपी रिवर्स डीएनएस की बात की
हमने रिवर्स डीएनएस मतलब पर्टिकुलर आईपी
का डोमेन आपको प्रोवाइड करेगा रिवर्स
डीएनएस में सेम वही चीज होती है जो कि आप
डीएन यू डीएन एक्स का यूज कर सकते हैं
रिवर्स डीएनएस के
लिए ठीक है रिवर्स डीएनएस के लिए आप नस
एक्स का यूज कर लीजिए जो एक पर्टिकुलर
लिस्ट ऑफ आईपी एड्रेसस है उससे एसोसिएटेड
डोमेन नेम जो होंगे वो आपको प्रोवाइड कर
देगा जैसे मेरे पास इसमें मान लो मेरे पास
एक आईपी की मेरे पास एक आईपी एड्रेस की
रेंज है मान लो यहां पे तो मैं डीएन एक्स
का यूज करके हान कर देते
हैं
एंड यहां पे लिस्ट ऑफ सब डोमस या होस्ट टू
रिजॉल्व यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं या डोमेन
लिस्ट ऑफ डोमेन टू ब्रूट फोर्स अगर डोमेन
चाहिए तो डोमेन है यहां पे लिस्ट ऑफ
वर्ड्स टू ब्रूट फोर्स तो यहां पे रिजॉल्व
के लिए हान एल लगा देते हैं तो डीएनएस
एक्स हान एल कर देते हैं एंड यहां पे
हमारे पास
apple.tv हमें क्या करना है तो हम यहां पे
यहां पे ऑप्शंस यहां पे दे रखे हैं हमें
पीटीआर चाहिए क्वेरी पीटीआर रिकॉर्ड तो
हाई हान पीटीआर ठीक है हाइन रेस्प हाइन
ओनली दे देते हैं रिस्पांस ओनली जो हमें
मिलेगी वही हमें चाहिए बस ओनली डिस्प्ले द
डीएनएस रिस्पांस ओनली और कुछ भी नहीं
चाहिए अगर आपको रिस्पांस कोड के थ्रू
डीएनएस स्टेटस कोड के थ्रू कुछ करना है तो
वो भी आप कर सकते हैं बट फिलहाल हमें कुछ
ऐसा नहीं करना है उसके बाद सीडीएन न बताना
है या डिस्प्ले होस्ट एसएन इंफॉर्मेशन अगर
कोई एसएन इंफॉर्मेशन होस्ट का डिस्प्ले
करना है तो वो भी आप दे सकते हैं हमें अभी
फिलहाल नहीं चाहिए कोई दिक्कत नहीं रेट
लिमिट डिसेबल्ड है डिफॉल्ट -1 है तो यहां
पे डिसेबल्ड है रेट लिमिट का फिलहाल
थ्रेड्स जो है डिफॉल्ट 100 है तो थ्रेड्स
को थोड़ा हम बढ़ा सकते हैं हान t को 100
को 1000 कर सकते हैं
[संगीत]
दैट्ची मिल जाएगी ठीक है रिक्वेस्ट यहां
पर आप देख सकते हैं 49 पर रिक्वेस्ट गई है
77 पर रिक्वेस्ट गई है टोटल होस्ट 16384
है और ये टोटली 100% हो चुका है इसका एंड
ट्स इट तो यहां पे हमारे को रिवर्स जो है
वो हमें डोमेन ने मिल चुका है जो भी उसमें
लिस्ट ऑफ आईपीस थी आपके पास ऐसे ही लाखों
आईपी एड्रेस हो सकती हैं एंड आप उस परे
ट्राई आउट कर सकते हो टू गेट
अ द डोमस जैसे हमें हमें यहां पे एल हमें
यहां प बहुत सारे मिल गए थे ना य 16000
कुछ आईपी एड्रेस मिल गए थे अगर
apple.id चलाता हूं हान सीआईडीआर एंड यहां
पे मैं इस सीआईडीआर को पेस्ट करता हूं तो
इसमें एल आईपी लार्ज एल आईपी लार्ज डटी
एकटी कर देता हूं मैं इस फाइल का नाम एंटर
करता हूं मैं यहां पे एलएस करता हूं कैट
एल आईपी लार्ज तो इसमें शायद वही थी 16000
हां 16000 वाली तो वही वाली फाइल थी ट्स
इट तो हमने वो सारी डोमेन जो है फाइंड की
रिवर्स डोमेन लुकअप के लिए होता है आईपी
एड्रेस राइट ट्स ल बस फिल
यस थैंक
यू क्लाउड फ्लेयर या हम अभी बहुत टॉपिक से
बहुत कुछ बात बहुत कुछ अभी करने वाले हैं
यार बहुत सारे टॉपिक्स बचे हुए हैं अभी
बहुत सारी चीजों को एक्सप्लेन करने वाले
हैं एंड मोस्ट प्रोबेबली इसका एक और पार्ट
भी आपको मिलेगा आज जो टॉपिक हुई है
स्कैनिंग टारगेट्स वाली इसका मोस्ट
प्रोबेबली एक और पार्ट जो है मैं लेकर
आऊंगा आपके लिए थोड़ा और कुछ जो है ना
आपको मैं और कुछ समझाऊ और भी कुछ चीजें
फाइंड करने की कोशिश करके आपको दिखाऊंगा
ताकि आपको और भी ज्यादा थोड़ा फील आ जाए
इसके अंदर में और आप इसको पूरी तरीके से
कंप्लीट कर पाए बट अभी तक जितने भी कराए
गए हैं टॉपिक जो भी चीजें कराई गई है
प्लीज उसपे प्रैक्टिस कीजिएगा जितना
प्रैक्टिस कीजिएगा उतना ही आपके लिए
बेनिफिशियल होगा प्रैक्टिस नहीं कीजिएगा
कोई बेनिफिट आपको नहीं मिलेगा जैसे यहां
पे हमारे स्टूडेंट्स जो भी हैं इस बग
बाउंट से सीख रहे हैं कुछ ना कुछ वो हमारे
डिफ्रॉक साइबर सिक्योरिटी को टैग करते हैं
जब भी जो भी सीखते हैं व सिंपल क्या करते
हैं यहां पे पोस्ट करते हैं और हमें टैग
करते हैं जैसे मैं एक्टिविटी पे चलता
हूं तो यहां पे मैं चलता हूं यहां पे यहां
पे जैसे इन्होंने टैग किया निखिल पटेल
करके हैं तो इस तरीके से आप भी अपनी जो भी
रिपोर्ट है जो भी एफर्ट है जो भी चीजें कर
रहे हैं आप जो भी चीजें आपको बाउंट नहीं
भी मिल रही है नहीं भी कुछ हो रहा है फिर
भी आप क्या कर रहे हैं वही करके और हमें
टैग कीजिए डिफ साइबर सिक्योरिटी को एंड वी
विल बी ग्लैड टू सी योर प्रोग्रेस ठीक है
हमें बहुत मजा आएगा उसके बाद हमारी एक चीज
और मैं बता देना चाहता हूं हमारा एक
कंप्लीट एथिकल हैकिंग का कोर्स है जो कि
आप हमारे इस पर्टिकुलर यूआरएल पे f.com
साइबर सिक्योरिटी मास्टरी कोर्स पे आके
एंड इनरोल कर सकते हैं एंड यह
डिस्क्रिप्शन में भी आपको लिंक मिल जाएगी
हमारा ए एप्लीकेशन है उसको जरूर इंस्टॉल
कर लीजिएगा डेनिक्स एडमी वहां पे आपको
सारे रिसोर्स फाइल जो हैं वो आपको मिलेंगे
ठीक है जो भी रिसोर्स फाइल्स हैं आपको वही
मिलेंगे फ्री वाली कोर्स के अंदर में ठीक
है
दैट्ची प्रैक्टिस नेक्स्ट क्लास के पहले
आपको 15th क्लास तक की पूरी प्रैक्टिस
करनी है रिवीजन करने है आपके जो भी
रिपोर्ट्स है वो लिंकन पर पोस्ट करके और
हमें टैग करना है सब लोग करेंगे जल्दी
बताइए मुझे एवरीवन विल डू
राइट एवरीवन विल
डू यस प्लीज रविन यू कैन फॉलो दैट रिकन
बाय जेसन डिक्स इज अ वेरी ग्रेट वीडियो
प्लीज यू कैन फॉलो
दैट
या मैं आपको बहुत कुछ बता रहा हूं जो मुझे
जो मैं नहीं भी बताता तो काम चल जाता बट
आपको मैं बहुत कुछ ऐसी चीजें बता रहा हूं
जो बाकी कहीं पर जल्दी लोग बताते नहीं है
कि किस तरीके से अप्रोच करना है क्याक
चीजें यूज करनी है तो कोई बात नहीं आप
सीखो कोई दिक्कत नहीं है सीखने
से मतलब रखना है और नॉलेज शेयरिंग से ही
बढ़ती है राइट
थैंक यू थैंक
यू या यू कैन चूज नॉटिलस इट्स अ ग्रेट
फील्ड राइट इट्स अ ग्रेट
फील्ड नेक्स्ट क्लास में मोस्ट प्रोबेबली
वन डे के गैप के बाद ही हो जाएगा आपका
परसों ही शायद हो जाएगा तो मैं आपको
इफॉर्म कर दूंगा
चैनल का लिंक मिल जाएगा प्लीज आप उसको
जवाइन कीजिए एंड दूसरों को भी बताया कीजिए
ठीक है इसी वीडियो के डिस्क्रिप्शन में
दैट्ची है लाऊंगा मैं लाऊंगा तो चलिए
मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट सेशन में गाइ एंड थैंक
यू फॉर जॉइनिंग द सेशन आई होप यू लर्न
समथिंग एंड